[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
weird days are upon us
strange history is being made
it's the news today
very diverse
hmm
well we will dig into it today is anyone
else dressing up for Halloween
I can't wear sunglasses I just I just
don't like the glasses I'll wear my hat
my Halloween hat how do you like it
can you guess I'm from the am I from the
80s or am I from the 90s I don't know
it's the best I can do for a Halloween
costume here on the Tony Michaels
podcast welcome welcome to the show it
is Friday you know what that means
bonehead of the week in the second hour
of the show the second hour of the show
bonehead of the week where you vote you
decide who is the bonehead of the week
and me and my co-host
rather he's at his home studio or
somewhere in a deep State bunker we will
break it down for you every single
Friday so don't forget to stay tuned for
all two hours um it sounds like there's
going to be
a press conference for Paul pelusi I'm
not really sure exactly on what time I
just uh someone had just messaged me so
I'm still checking into that as we speak
and we will um if if we can cover that I
don't know if you guys know the news but
Paul Pelosi was attacked in his home
there was a break-in and the news is
that someone used a hammer if you guys
don't know who Paul Pelosi is he is the
husband of the Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi of course the right wing is
absolutely going oh you can't tell him
violence and crap crap Democrat Joe
Baden yeah uh laptops and and um uh see
you got to build a wall they don't have
a really good excuse for political
violence
because there is no excuse there's no
excuse for political violence there's no
excuse for threats
there's no excuse to harass
there's just none other than they're
losing
Steve scalise says this morning that
America is going the way of of Italy to
the right
if you don't get out and vote if you
don't make your [ __ ] voice heard it
just may
and there may be more of this type of
violence and there may not be any
investigations behind it
that's what happens in far-right
countries in authoritarian regimes
that's what happens
so what are you going to decide this
morning
as we're watching history be made
of a speaker of the house spouse
being brutally beaten with a hammer in
the privacy of their own home
because why because you're scared of
Nancy Pelosi that's the actual facts
they are terrified terrified of Nancy
Pelosi folks absolutely terrified
they're terrified that she's going to
remain the Speaker of the House
so much so that they're willing to break
in and brutally beat her spouse her
husband her husband
to try to scare her away and I doubt it
works I doubt it works
that's one thing that these right-wing
little pukes do not understand they
don't get it
Liberals are not weak you dumb
[ __ ]
they won't they will not they will not
Scurry for threats
you actually there are people out there
that believe that Democrats
don't own weapons
two abros
running around talking about the Second
Amendment how cool they are
and they don't realize that there's a
lot of people out there that have that
same right
and they exercise the right to bear arms
there's a lot of them that don't
understand that
there's a lot of them that don't
understand there's people all over this
country not just in blue states are in
San Francisco where they where they went
to attack Nancy Pelosi's husband they
don't understand that people will stand
for democracy and we're not just going
to give it away Jesus Christ this
morning on on Twitter constitutional
republic is trending and I'm sure
constitutional republic is trending
because they don't understand that a
constitutional republic is a democracy
they don't [ __ ] get it
they forgot to go Google the [ __ ]
words before they started tweeting about
how we're not in democracy we're a
constitution Republic because this is
the [ __ ] this is what the media is
feeding you is that the Democrats have
already lost
don't count your chickens for the hatch
[ __ ]
it is up to you I'm telling you it is up
to you
what this makeup of this country is
going to be
in two weeks
you must not be afraid you must not
relent
lean in now is the time
they think we're weak
good luck
good luck with your little stupid
narrative Steve scalise
good luck with it
there was a video
of a southern a southern candidate for
governor that looks like it's from 1963.
saying out loud into a microphone that
marriage is between one man one woman
and my Bible says this my Bible says
that and I'm old-fashioned and blah blah
blah yakety smackity
we are not that country
that is not Who We Are
you know that I know that
a lot of people in this country know
that because most people in this country
don't give a [ __ ] flying [ __ ]
who you love
you want to love somebody [ __ ] love
them more power to you
matter of fact good luck with that
marriage thing because it's a difficult
Union
no matter who you are everyone knows
that that's ever been married
it's a hard partnership it really is a
hard partnership
but here's the thing
if you think you're gonna run around
and tell people that they must tell
other people what the [ __ ] to do
that's literally what they're saying is
they're trying to gather up the shark
army
of people telling their neighbors and
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] they're gonna do when
they don't want to be told what to do
it's a really hard narrative that
they're trying on the American people
and it's a fraud that people are
believing it
it's a [ __ ] fraud
that people in this country really think
that they want to tell who who they can
and cannot marry this is stupid [ __ ]
and it goes well beyond that single that
Singularity of that right way beyond
that I mean you're talking about Dr Oz
saying that they want local politicians
in the doctor's office with you making
your decisions about your your uterus
what
local politics what the [ __ ] does the
mayor have to do
with what medical procedures you get
I've never heard that [ __ ] in my
entire [ __ ] life
I've been here for almost 40 years never
[ __ ] heard that [ __ ] ever
in the in the American culture that I
grew up in never heard that the mayor
the local politician should tell you
what to do in your doctor's office
think about how far off the [ __ ]
rails they are
how desperate they are to gain some
support somewhere
they have no ideas they have no policy
and the reason why is because they can't
they can't have an idea think about this
for a second just just think about the
one thing they [ __ ] they tweet about
the most gas prices and inflation think
about this for a second
if they actually had a [ __ ] idea in
their brain about how to help with gas
prices and inflation
it would be something that the Biden
Administration is already doing
it listen to me when I say this when it
comes to gas prices and inflation if the
Republicans the fascist the America
First Nazis came up with an idea which
they don't have if they came up with an
idea to combat inflation
the Biden Administration would already
be doing it they're already doing it
the FED is already doing it
that's why they can't
they're so [ __ ] politically inept
that they have to resort to demonizing
people who are on the margins of society
who are already demonized in the first
place by the scuzzes it's the scuzziest
of the scumbags like Matt Walsh and Ben
Shapiro
the likes of Tucker Carlson
where they demonize someone because they
truly have an identity crisis in their
life
because they are a certain sexuality and
they love a certain person
think about it
they can't have no [ __ ] Solution on
gas prices they can't have a [ __ ]
Solution on inflation or Health Care our
education or anything for that matter
and the reason why is because they're so
unreasonable
they're so unreasonable in fact that
they won't let their lips leave Putin's
ass
long enough
someone tweeted this this morning
they won't let their lips leave Putin's
ass long enough
to say something
about the political violence against
Paul Pelosi
speaking of Putin
the Cheeto dust mobster says he's not
going to leave true social
says he's going to uh remain there he's
not going to go to Twitter
so I don't know who denied his request I
don't know if Elon
you know text him this morning
and said hey
um I'm not going to or if Elon that's
why he was talking to Putin because
Putin doesn't want Trump back on Twitter
I don't know I'm not sure which of the
of the far right hierarchy is making the
decision for Trump not to be back on
Twitter
I know maybe he comes back on Twitter
live on air I don't know who knows I
actually do not believe that it's a bad
idea for Trump to come back on Twitter
what the [ __ ] the difference
you know I believe in sunlight the is
the best disinfectant
and right now he's only yelling and
screaming
into the right-wing Echo chamber that's
it the only way that he gets exposed is
if we say he's what he's saying and show
what he's saying
otherwise he's stoking people that went
to the same people that went to Paul and
Nancy Pelosi's house this morning with a
hammer
the media the media Focus so hard on
Kanye West anti-semitic tropes and his
racism and his anti-Semitism and his
bigotry
that they missed that the former
president of the United States told
American Jewish people you either you
either get it together and support me or
go the [ __ ] back to Israel before it's
too late
that's what he said he [ __ ] posted it
no one said a word I mean I said [ __ ]
I I'm saying it now
that's why they don't like when I talk
we're in a crucial time
it's Do or Die folks
so what are you gonna do are you gonna
sit at home and not vote I doubt it
but are you just gonna vote is that all
you're going to do
are you gonna find three friends three
family members colleagues fellow
parishioners
and encourage them to lean into
democracy encourage them to vote
and encourage them to find three others
to encourage
it's it's go time folks this turnout is
what's going to save democracy
it's the turnout that will save
democracy and the reason why is because
the majority of Americans don't want
what Steve scalise is talking about
it we don't want to go back to a time
where people have to hide because of
their sexuality or who they love this is
really [ __ ] stupid
it's dumb as dog [ __ ]
we do not want women dying because they
can't make reasonable [ __ ] medical
decisions about their bodies and their
uteruses
in the privacy of their doctor's office
without having a local politician or any
politician having their head in there
and it's headed far beyond that that's
only the start
that's where they start folks that's not
where it ends
that's where this kind of nonsense
starts
and yeah I know everyone's upset about
Twitter this morning
listen
it's time to go scorched Earth on these
[ __ ]
it's time to show them what democracy
really does
it's time to show them what the weight
of the people can do
now is the time
right now because this in this moment in
history
when democracy wins when democracy
prevails
and the world sees that the United
States of America
is not a fascist state
that that is all [ __ ]
that's all a ruse that's all a fraud
that half the country supports Trump you
are some dumb [ __ ] if you're
out there thinking half the country
supports this idiot you are a stupid
bastard
dumb [ __ ]
so what are you gonna do that's the
question today and that's the question
you should be asking
folks
you should be asking them that
the Paul Pelosi story great story to
start with great story to start with
it's hard to talk about you don't want
to say you know
a politician got
their house broken into and their
husband
was beat up with the hammer to an inch
of their life
because of politics
is that who you want in charge
you want the people who who encouraged
and who incited someone to go to
someone's house
beat them with a hammer because they
don't have good ideas folks you think
the guy carrying the hammer had a had a
good argument
for inflation
you think the guy with the hammer had a
good argument for gas prices
sounds like he ran out of arguments to
me
what do you think
where's your head at
do you think you think someone running
around beating people with a hammer
because they disagree with him
politically or they're terrified
of Nancy Pelosi being the speaker of the
house again
I know the media is telling you that the
Republicans are going to win I know
they're saying that [ __ ] I know that the
political pundits out there are hedging
their bet I had someone message me about
David packman and I haven't really said
anything about David packman on this
show but [ __ ] that guy
[ __ ] him
and [ __ ] anyone else there that has this
defeatist attitude
that believes that believes that the
only way for them to advance their
stupid political [ __ ] punditry is to
buy into [ __ ]
you can be wrong hell I may be [ __ ]
wrong I don't give a [ __ ] that's not the
point
this is why Democrats always get
defeated because they're defeated before
it even [ __ ] starts you talk about
polling the only poll that [ __ ]
matters is the one on Election Day
that's the one that [ __ ] matters
dummies
oh Tony don't attack left-wing media
don't attack tyt The Young Turks and
David packman well maybe they should get
off their asses and realize this is not
[ __ ] 10 years ago
and you you trying to use polls and the
fact that the Republicans are going to
win the house and as a tool to try to
scare people into going to vote is
really stupid
it's really stupid
you want to know what gets people fired
up do you want to know what gets him
ready to fight a voice like mine that's
right
yeah I'll Pat myself on the back you
guys come here every single day you're
the best audience in the world I truly
believe that
there's nothing there's nothing that
anyone could ever say to me that
wouldn't
convince me that you are
you're in the chat every single day not
even talking about politics you're
lifting each other up
sending each other off with a better
attitude than when you came in that's
the most important part that's the
that's the cathartic part about this
show every every single weekday for two
goddamn hours that's why I'm here
and for lame [ __ ] to be having
a defeatist attitude they're they're not
helping our side
they're not under the pro-democracy tent
as far as I can tell what are you doing
then
democracy is not built
on defeat
it's built on Hope
and what you can do and what you will do
and what the people will do with you
that's how we reach a point to where we
are satisfied with equality and equity
and really frankly I hope we never reach
that point
I hope this country stays strong and the
democracy is here for many decades to
come many centuries to come
and we never are satisfied with the
amount of equity inequality that means
we're still striving for more and more
and more
that's what I want
that's why Yellen scream
it's important
that this democracy live
this constitutional republic which is a
democracy right-wingers hate Watchers
listening who don't know definitions to
words
this Democratic constitutional republic
should live
it should live
with all its tainted history
with all the [ __ ] that we have inside of
it now All the Troubles all the
institutional problems
that may exist it is worth
the experiment continuing
and to be defeatist about that
to feel defeated before you even open
the polls in some states
you're weak
you're [ __ ] weak
and you can go out there and tell them I
said it tweet at him I don't give a [ __ ]
cut this cut this clip out and show it
to him
the Democratic party of old
is gone
the new Democratic party is here and
it's pro-democracy
it's not defeatist
and people are getting sick and tired of
hearing weak ass messaging
trying to get people to to be weak
because they're not
so get in line get in shape we got we
got we got just over a week to do this
just over a week it's October 28th folks
we got just over a goddamn week
to make sure that we save our democracy
and this is the most important election
of our democracy's lifetime and I think
everyone understands that everyone
understands it
even the people like Steve scalise
you're like oh I hope I hope the Nazis
come out and vote for us I hope the
fascist we can get our our toothless
redneck fascists out there to vote for
us uh-huh I hope we can convey I hope we
can lie to them about gas prices I hope
we can lie to them this morning died
suddenly is trending because there's
some kind of new documentary about lies
about the about the vaccine and I'm
almost positive I'm almost positive
that this dropped
after the SpaceX [ __ ]
has taken over
what do you think and the other question
the other question I want you to uh
roll around this weekend as Halloween
comes
uh is Donald Trump going to be back on
Twitter oh my God I hope so I know you
yeah I know everyone's out there it's
like Tony God damn it you son of a I I
hope so oh my I can't I cannot wait
I cannot I know I don't go in the
comments much
I don't get into threads much I just
don't
I can't wait I can't I I you know I love
the quote tweet I'm gonna be quote
tweeting the [ __ ] out of that guy [ __ ]
him we'll see how much freedom of speech
we have
on Twitter we'll see how free speech is
we'll see if we have to pay for it or
not everybody thanks for joining me on
this Friday you know today is Friday so
we do bonehead of the week in the second
hour Gabe Sanchez is back today
he's in an undisclosed secret deep State
location
again
um he's again he's he's working hard for
that CIA deep state that we've got oh my
God it you know
he's a Fed so he's got to work hard
traveling around
uh Gabe Sanchez is going to join us
today for bonehead of the week in the
second hour where you vote you decide
who is the bonehead of the week we break
it down every single Friday so don't
forget to subscribe right here on
YouTube you can vote here on YouTube you
can also go vote at Tony Michael's pod
on Twitter but also don't forget to
download every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify
and Google the last few days I've had
trouble with my editing software it it I
don't know what's going on but
uh I've been like getting my episodes up
there a couple hours behind so people
were worried but I put them up every
single day every single day on Apple
Spotify you go while you're there
subscribing make sure to leave a great
review the trolls have been leaving
reviews so you gotta you gotta
counteract them leave the review on your
favorite directory while you're
subscribing and if you're on Facebook I
know you're out there watching on
Facebook
go follow at the Tony Michaels help us
out over on my page if you're on Midas
Touch page on Facebook go follow me on
Facebook also look if you're looking for
a little different chat experience you
can go over to Twitch some people like
it over there they like the chat over
there so you can go follow us on Twitch
as well simple download of the app on
your phone doesn't cost anything free
you can watch for free I don't I don't
get my content so if you go to Twitch
you're not gonna you're not gonna pay to
watch
um now if you have I know they have run
commercials
um and during certain parts of the
episode I I don't control that but if
you that's twitch doing it I think but
you can tie your your your Amazon
account to it or something like that I
don't I don't know I don't know go to
the twitch chat and ask the people there
they'll know exactly what to do if
there's commercials and how to but I
don't get my content I don't gate it
it's free it's it's a hundred percent
for you to watch to listen to every
single weekday Monday through Friday day
for two full hours noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific wherever you're
watching rather it's YouTube twitch
Twitter Facebook whether you're
listening to it on the ad the Apple
podcast on Spotify on Google wherever
you are getting it it is a hundred
percent free and we run off your support
and how we run off your support is the
great support you give because you are
the greatest audience in the world
you guys share you you're you're
tweeting you're sharing the episode with
your family your friends the audience is
growing every single day and if and if
you want to support us I don't know if
you see this here the lock Em Up Banner
that's brand new lock Em Up Banner brand
new
and the merch store brand new you just
go to
store.dtonymichaels.com if you want to
grab a lock him up Banner
store.thetonymichaels.com and while
you're there grab a sweater it's getting
cold out there Everyone likes these
Liberty sweaters the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people is not
Liberty it is our show motto grab it in
a zip up Hoodie a pullover hoodie a
sweater or maybe even just grab the the
T-shirt a lot of people like the T-shirt
as well go to
store.dtonymichaels.com boy that's been
the greatest support of all you guys
really like this design I don't know
what do you guys think of the uh the
lock Em Up manner what do you think you
want to get there here let's do this
there you go now you see a little better
right over here right over my shoulder
there lock him up lock him up lock him
up lock him up everyone stick around
we're gonna get to the [ __ ] list Roundup
we're gonna surf the Tweety tweets and
trendy Trends it's a historic day stick
around we'll be right back right after
these messages
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this
Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
what do you think
today's a weird day in history a lot of
different news going on
but the good news is Gabe Sanchez is
here now with us for bonehead of the
week I believe
I don't know he hadn't really confirmed
it yet
I think he is I think he's gonna be what
do you think you think he'll be here you
think he'll show up
from his undisclosed deep State bunker I
don't know
and I guess we'll I guess we'll find out
I guess we'll find out oh
yeah I tell you what
it's been it's been quite the week but
we are here it is Friday
we're at the bottom of the first hour
and we're gonna do a little bit of
shitless Roundup
uh I I there's a lot of video
um out there
uh going around but uh and I'm still
trying to figure out exactly what the um
what the situation is with uh Paul
Pelosi and the press conference so
hopefully we will get to that
um as soon as we can I I don't know does
anyone have the
um the time on it uh the Paul Pelosi
let's see if I can go to let's just
let's just go to Twitter here
let's see if we can find it here uh
trending Paul Pelosi let's see if we can
find this press conference
um
again
and I haven't played the shitless round
of Music yet I know that but
um here's from Kyle this is an hour ago
suspect who attacked Paul Pelosi uh
house speaker's husband uh specifically
targeted their home I wonder why I
wonder what that I wonder why that is
yeah
hmm I wonder what the the target could
be
and Texas ball has been tweeting let's
see what he says
um if I can get there we go pop Pelosi
is 82 years old and they're celebrating
the beating
and the hospitalization of an 82 year
old man [ __ ] vote people vote vote
vote vote
yeah so they're they're they're
celebrating this uh we'll retweet Paul
here thank you Paul for your
your Tweet
um let's see what else we got here again
this is uh this is
really
um
this is a very significant point
in history we are we are less than two
weeks away
from one of the most important elections
of our country's history right now in
this in our time it is the most
important election of our democracy's
history
and the Speaker of the House
had her home broken into targeted uh
with some weirdo psychopath creep and I
I wonder if I could have to even guess
who they support politically hmm I
wonder
to um
break into their house Target their
house and to beat her husband the
speaker's husband with a hammer
now you know that Paul Pelosi has
trended several times on Twitter he had
a he had an incident with the law where
he got pulled over I guess he blew hot
and got a DUI
and I don't know if um anyone knows
that are knew who Paul Pelosi was before
that started trending but the right ring
really stoked this this this froth oh
look he got a DUI which I'm not I'm not
condoning it
I'm not condoning it by any stretch of
the matter
but the punishment for a DUI is not for
people to seek you out at your home and
beat you with a hammer and that's not
why they went there
they went there because they're
terrified of Nancy Pelosi they're
terrified that the Democrats are going
to win the house
and they're trying to strike fear
into people in this country
well you must not be afraid
we must not relent
you cannot give up trust me you have to
keep speaking out for your democracy
uh JoJo from Jersey says if we find out
definitely
that the attack on Paul Pelosi was
politically motivated who other
Republicans going to blame instead oh
they've all I'll tell you they're
already blaming oh bad and you're bad
and
yeah man I'm sure
um cokehead Junior will be doing a video
tonight talking about how it's somehow a
laptop's fault I'm sure a laptop has a
lot to do with this now of course you
see a lot of uh Democratic politicians
speaking out against this you probably
won't see too many Republicans at this
point that are going to speak out
against this as a as a political attack
they're going to talk about crime crabs
up because of jupited
and you already saw Fox news this
morning
um capitulating to this idea
pushing this idea I'm here uh Scott
McFarland has something and let's see uh
he says uh
sources sources if I can get it there
you go sources briefed on attack
residents in San Francisco's ship San
Francisco tell CBS News the assailant
who attacked Paul Pelosi was in search
of Speaker of the House
uh-oh uh oh a rat row before assault
occurred Intruder confronted Mr Pelosi
shouting where is Nancy where is Nancy
okay listen listen listen when I tell
you this listen when I tell you this
this is what they want this is what
Trump wants
this is what Blake Masters this is this
is what Dr Oz this is what Herschel
Walker this is what Ron DeSantis this is
what Greg Abbott this is what they want
this is what they want even Ted Cruz Ted
Cruz says here what happened to Paul
Pelosi last night is horrific Heidi and
I are praying oh Ted oh you're praying
thank God thank God take Chris is
praying again oh my God thank God him
and Heidi are praying
and Nancy and for for him Nancy and her
Tire family my God's protection may
God's protection be upon them
we can have our political difference but
violence is always wrong and
unacceptable I love how you're covering
your tracks there Ted
I love how you're covering your tracks
with thoughts and prayers like you do
when little children are ripped apart in
elementary schools
by weapons of war
because you won't do anything besides
talk about back doors and how tall
fences are you piece of [ __ ] garbage
you did this Ted you did this you did
this you dumb [ __ ]
you people capitulating to the people
who wanted to kill her on January 6. oh
they're political prisoners
it wasn't actually it wasn't actually a
[ __ ] Insurrection Nancy Pelosi she
she's the one she's the one who did this
she's the one who did that
it's you Ted
you [ __ ] pile of [ __ ]
you know how you hold takers accountable
because I know you can't go vote for Ted
Cruz right now
if you're in Texas you know your old
Tech Cruise accountable
go vote
Democrat all the way down the [ __ ]
ticket [ __ ] Ted Cruz
you know how you get at Ted Cruz if
you're in any other state besides Texas
go vote Democrat all the way down the
[ __ ] ticket
make Nancy Pelosi the Speaker of the
House
make sure Chuck Schumer has 53 Senators
to filibuster
Ted Cruz can go kick [ __ ] rocks all
the way down to Cancun [ __ ] him and
anyone who looks like him
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] this little uh my
thoughts and prayers thoughts and
prayers [ __ ] out of here Ted go get in
front of a microphone and decry to cry
your book
that capitulates to the people who
wanted to go [ __ ] kill Nancy Pelosi
on January 6 because you had the
narrative that the election could be
overthrown with an Insurrection you pile
of [ __ ] because you still [ __ ]
believe in the big lie you [ __ ]
if you really are so Christian if you
really want your God's protection to be
upon them and you and your family then
what you should do Ted is repent
Now's the Time Ted Cruz [ __ ] your tots
and pears [ __ ] them you pile of garbage
you pile a [ __ ] [ __ ] running around
the country going on TV selling your
stupid [ __ ] book with the big [ __ ]
lie because it's good for you because
you would put yourself in a position
where you're Donald Trump's little
[ __ ] [ __ ] Ted Cruz
you're his little [ __ ] Cheeto ass
dust Tavern [ __ ] Ted Cruz
everybody knows it even Heidi
you're [ __ ] weak
not surprising that you're weak
everybody cut this [ __ ] up put it online
tag tag Cruise [ __ ] them
I'm sure parts of the media be like oh
Ted Cruz offers his thoughts and pray
well at least Ted Cruz said something
[ __ ] him
he has he has said a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ]
that led this led us to this point of
him having to tweet his thoughts and
payers just like all the [ __ ] he's done
to have to [ __ ] tweet out cops and
pairs when little elementary school
children are [ __ ] ripped apart by a
[ __ ] semi-automatic rifle
it's the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
from these weak bastards the same
[ __ ]
anything for a [ __ ] dollar huh Ted
Cruz anything for a [ __ ] dollar for
your stupid [ __ ] book a big a big
live book
spreading lies around the country
capitulating to [ __ ] election fraud
[ __ ] nonsense
calling calling the people who wanted to
kill Nancy Pelosi the same [ __ ]
who now you're saying is wrong and
unacceptable came to the [ __ ]
building where you worked to try to kill
her
you stupid [ __ ]
go to Twitter right now because if
there's free speech on Twitter baby
Free Speech go go right now and tell Ted
Cruz how you feel about his tots and his
[ __ ] pair prep pears you can take
your tots and payers takers and stick
them up your [ __ ] ass
Ted Cruz did this
that's right the Republican Party Ted
Cruz Donald Trump Mitch McConnell the
rest of them they all did this Josh
Hawley
Paul gozar
you piece of garbage
Steve scalise Kevin McCarthy you [ __ ]
weak [ __ ]
you [ __ ] weak [ __ ] and you
know why you know why they capitulate to
these [ __ ] fools do you know why Ted
Cruz capitulates
to to what he calls political Prisoners
the insta violent insurrectionist on
January 6 because they're scared they're
gonna come to their house with hammers
they're scared of them they're [ __ ]
Ted Cruz is a punk ass [ __ ]
that's what it is
so if political violence is so wrong and
so unacceptable they get out front of a
microphone and tell us that you're not
going to release this book of big lies
that spreads violence that is that is
wrong and unacceptable Ted tell us that
you you repudiate everything you said in
your [ __ ] book that is just outright
political lies designed to stoke fear
and violence
for profit for profit for a dollar
because you don't want tots and pears
you want to give tots and payers so that
you can get profits
[ __ ] Ted Cruz [ __ ] them
is that enough that you guys want more
you guys want more of me going after Ted
Cruz I don't know maybe
oh boy now it's gonna end up on the
internet somewhere
yeah I'm serious though [ __ ] Ted Cruz
[ __ ] that sumbitch
any one of these [ __ ] that
comes out today and gives tots and Pairs
and isn't absolutely decrying every any
politician
any politician who is who is
perpetuating any kind of lie about
January 6 at all even just the slight
stench of it
is capitulating to the person who broke
into the house looking for Nancy Pelosi
with a hammer you're capitulating to
that [ __ ] and people like them
you stupid [ __ ] so I don't want your
thoughts and prayers you can take your
thoughts and payers and stick them up
your [ __ ] ass
all the way up in there and twist that
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and your
God I don't need it anymore no one's
playing that [ __ ]
if you're so Godly if you're so
religious
then get off your ass and stop lying to
the American people
stop playing your [ __ ] about oh
January's thick their political prison
everyone know they're one of violent
Insurrection on Jerry's we didn't try to
make sure that Donald Trump remained
King even though the people spoke or
everything there's election fraud oh
voting machines voting machines you dumb
[ __ ] did this
you killed Ashley Babbitt you [ __ ]
idiots
you got Ashley Babbitt killed
hell you got this guy out in San
Francisco so stoked up that he was gonna
go kill Nancy Pelosi that now that
motherfucker's gonna be in prison
probably for the rest of his goddamn
life
because you think it's cute to bang up
our democracy
because it helps you sell books or it
gives you power
cause God forbid God forbid
you go against your orange Mussolini
Jesus
at all
that's how you react to him I'm just
just saying okay everybody we're gonna
go to the Tweety tweets and the trendy
Trends because we're gonna have to get
to the uh the bonehead of the week we
know we do bone of the week every single
Friday here on the Tony Michaels podcast
and the second hour is coming up quick
knew that rant on Ted Cruz was a long
one uh so everyone surfed the Tweety
tweets and The Trinity Trends start the
countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
apparently everyone liked what I had to
say about Ted Cruz it's exactly what
they're thinking
I just I
got loud I don't give a [ __ ] nah I don't
care anymore I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
gonna say what I want to say and
apparently because I can stream this to
Twitter now so I get to say whatever the
hell it is that I want to say there's no
way that they can do anything about my
speech over there because it's
completely free
completely free I have to pay for none
of it
it's free over there now
speaking to Twitter oh boy yeah boy
let's see what we got on the Tweety
tweets and attorney Trends this morning
as we wait um for the second hour to
come here on the Tony Michaels podcast
you think he's gonna come crawling back
what do you think
he put out a statement this morning
you know the Cheeto dust mobster like I
said I am not opposed to Trump coming
back to Twitter I actually think it'll
be [ __ ] fun
funner than [ __ ] I think it'd be funner
than [ __ ] here's here's his post on true
social I post this stuff so you don't
have to
listen again this is why I think it's so
important
because he posts a lot of dumb [ __ ] okay
he posts a lot of stupid [ __ ] because
he's a dumb [ __ ] he's a dumb [ __ ] but
what are you gonna do I don't know what
are you gonna do yesterday there was a
sealed [ __ ] hearing yesterday about
this documents case because they're
trying to figure out where else this
motherfucker's hiding documents because
the Department of Justice and Nara know
that he's still got documents he's still
obstructing justice as we speak my guess
is after the the midterm
[ __ ] is gonna be banged up in
court big time
maybe be arraigned hopefully there's
some sealed documents for an indictment
on this [ __ ] it's time it's time
it's time for them to act okay so here's
what he tweets about about Twitter
um because he knows he wants back on
Twitter right uh he knows he wants back
on Twitter
he doesn't know if he's going to get
back onto it maybe he's text Elon I
don't know maybe he text Elon and his
boss Putin because Putin's the one that
controls Donald Trump and Elon but let's
listen you doubt me doubt me okay here
is here is um here's Donald Trump he
said true social in all caps again is
really kind of weird has become somewhat
of a phenomenon yeah like um it's
amazing that the fraud even exists
last week he says
it had bigger numbers than all platforms
including Tick Tock Twitter and Facebook
and the rest not sure what the rest
means I guess maybe Instagram or parlor
or and I think he's knocking on other
right wing when he says the rest I don't
know uh he goes on to say it also looks
and works better to my eye
so he likes the way that that true
social looks it looks just like Twitter
I don't know if you've been over there
but if you don't know it it looks like
they copied their source code I just
lifted it
like it looks almost it's it's really
it's not as
um it's not as easy to use because it's
a pile of [ __ ] of course but they pretty
much made the look of it Twitter that's
what they're trying to go for
he goes on to say I am very happy that
Twitter is now insane hands he refers to
Elon Musk as sane okay that's where
we're at and he also goes on to say and
will no longer be run by radical left
lunatics and Maniacs that truly hate our
country
I don't know what he's exactly talking
about there with the lunatics the
radical left lunatics and Maniacs I'm
not sure exactly what that means maybe
that's why Elon started firing people he
thought they were part of the I don't
know cabal I have no idea uh the Cheeto
dust mobster goes on to say on true
social Twitter must now work hard
to rid itself of all the Bots and fake
accounts so he's bought into Elon Musk
is [ __ ] that have heard it so badly
because the the reason why Elon tried to
back out he tried so many things to back
out of this deal
he tried really hard not to overpay for
Twitter on a gag on Twitter like
literally he said I'm gonna buy Twitter
and then he said I'm gonna buy it for
this much and it was it was a it was a
[ __ ] gag and then he took it way too
far and now he's way overpaid for
Twitter way overpaid you should be
excited about that by the way I'm
telling you you should be excited about
it I know it doesn't feel like it in the
moment but you should be really excited
that Elon Musk overpaid way overpaid for
Twitter
now
Donald Trump goes on to say
it will be much smaller but better I
love truth
so the indication is here that that
everyone's Gonna Leave right that's what
he's saying that he they're gonna leave
Twitter the fake accounts in the Bots
he's talking about left Wingers the the
radical left Luna Dixon Maniacs is what
he's talking about here that's what I
see it as
and he's saying it'll be much smaller
but better but better I love truth so
he's not saying he loves true social and
he's going to stay on true social but my
take of it is is that he is not getting
his account back today
on Twitter I want him to have it back I
think that should have been the first
thing that Elon Musk did was give Donald
Trump his account back on Twitter
I want to start quote tweeting that
[ __ ] who else is excited
is totally excited about quote tweeting
and putting the comments you know that
[ __ ] goes through and reads
those some [ __ ]
why wouldn't you want to put a Post-It
note right inside that motherfucker's
brain
huh that's incredible well think about
the power that we will have over him
when he's reading our comments and
reading our quote tweets and we're
dragging him
do the scorched Earth fire of democracy
on Twitter I mean it's gonna be free
speech right right
that's what they say that's what they're
telling us
I mean you know the right wing isn't
much interested in free speech so we'll
see how long that that narrative lasts
but I can't wait I can't wait to have my
Twitter accounts permanently banned
because Donald Trump is a weak [ __ ]
he's a weakling and right Wingers are
weak
I'll just have to open up sock accounts
I guess I don't know
let's see um here is um
oh no that that that's not the one I'm
looking for now what am I looking for I
thought I tweeted it I don't know maybe
I didn't retweet this I was looking at a
lot of stuff this morning
I told you guys that the other day the
um uh
big secret of mine is how I do some of
my shows I'm retweeting stuff oh there's
this great video uh of Ben Shapiro at
his best he is he is he is pro
transgender folks now in this video now
there's been a few um um recent videos
of Ben Shapiro in support of fetterman
and now in support
of transgender people but let's watch
this video from Fox this morning
where they just can't figure out
they can't figure it out here of why
what would motivate what would motivate
a person to just show up at the Speaker
of the House
resonance with a hammer to kill someone
they can't figure it out let's see if
they come to some conclusion they won't
contributor leaders a lot we do not hang
on let me get the volume up here
maybe this will help no okay uh the AP
says he was severely beaten we don't
know how we got in we don't know whether
he was letting we don't know if he knew
Paul Pelosi whether
uh this is all done we don't know huh we
have no idea blah blah blah that didn't
last very long when the facts come out
this is this is how stupid this is
how [ __ ] dumb this is
how dumb the media is in general not
just Fox News the media in general
how the [ __ ] can't you see what this is
like in the snap of a finger of course
we know what this is
of course we know
everyone's been waiting on pins and
needles to see what violence is going to
take place
I mean Jesus Christ the FBI goes to
Mar-A-Lago does a legal search
executes a search warrant Donald Trump
screams and yells about how the FBI is
evil people show up at FBI headquarters
with the nail gun shooting people and
people like oh I wonder if that has
anything to do with Mar-A-Lago and the
Trump support of course it does
of course it does I I wonder I wonder if
if all the videos that have been put out
there about Nancy Pelosi because the
January 6th Select Committee
expose the video where she's like he
better not come down to the Capitol I
will punch him in his face
I wonder if that has anything to do with
it
all the videos and all the rhetoric that
has been hyped up
because there was a violent Insurrection
where they tried to kill Nancy Pelosi
and they're still lying about it
still to this day
we're almost two years there past the
event and they're still [ __ ] lying
after all the evidence that has been
laid before the American people there's
still gaslighting their supporters
they're still deluding them and to
stoking violence
we've talked about it several times with
Dakota Adams Stewart Rhodes is a strange
son here on the on the Tony Michaels
podcast he's told you time and time
again
and he knows the militia attitude he
knows the militia he knows the mindset
of these folks
and they're stoking stochastic to
terrorism let's listen there's a
complete stranger but the um write-up is
that quote the motivation is still under
investigation I want to be a little
careful on the story we don't know yet
we don't know how he's going to pull out
of it Leo
well first of all I hope he has a full
recovery and I think that's the first
thing I want to say and secondly I
believe there's also a suspect in
custody but the bigger problem bill is
simply this uh crime does not
discriminate rich or poor Black or White
City suburbs everywhere it's everywhere
is the number one issue in this country
okay Leo you dumb [ __ ]
how in the [ __ ] don't they know that
crime discriminates how the [ __ ] don't
they know this
how in the absolutely [ __ ] don't they
know this
how do they [ __ ] live with themselves
by spreading even more lies on Fox news
this morning about about this attack
this political attack on the Speaker of
the House
dude thought she was at the house and
this is really how dumb Trump supporters
are
is that I don't know if they believe
that she flies home every night to San
Francisco
after she's done with her work on
Washington
the hill
if she just flies home every single
night I don't know I would imagine they
just don't know all kinds of [ __ ] these
Maga trumped up [ __ ] are just
delusional as [ __ ] they have no idea how
anything Works none of it
but here Fox News is continuing to stoke
the violence
by saying well we don't know and
violence uh violence doesn't
discriminate wink
wink
come on
Leo here even tweeted about it I'm not
[ __ ] you Leo here tweeted about it
let me show you his tweet I I quote
tweeted him because I have freedom of
speech
and I definitely have the freedom on
Twitter for sure uh for sure I have the
I I have the complete full ability to
tweet whatever I want whenever I want
however I want uh Leo here here's his
account he says attention this is he's
he's
he is sending a threat
dude that was just on Fox News the clip
that I just showed you is sending
threats
attention Paul and Nancy Pelosi crime
does not discriminate
and of course I said you're a dumb [ __ ]
because he's a dumb [ __ ]
number one crime does discriminate
number two you're sending a threat
you're threatening Paul and Nancy Pelosi
in this [ __ ] how else can you see it
Paul Pelosi just got attacked by someone
breaking into their house with a [ __ ]
Hammer looking for Nancy Pelosi because
people like Leo go on Fox News and
spread lies and dilute people and [ __ ]
mind [ __ ] him into believing [ __ ] that
just isn't [ __ ] true Leo you [ __ ]
idiot
you are a dumb [ __ ] Leo
and here he is threatening crime doesn't
discriminate attention
Paul Pelosi who is in the hospital
fighting for his life because he got
smashed with a hammer
because dumb [ __ ] like Leo here spread
lies on big media Outlets
about Nancy Pelosi the speaker of the
house which the person was looking for
to kill her the same the same
[ __ ] probably
who was looking for her on January 6th
because of the lies that were spread on
I don't know Fox News
from people like Leo
stochastic terrorism when they actually
posted a banner in Texas at CPAC do you
remember this they had a seat pack down
in Texas they invited the Hungarian
Hitler Orban there because they love
fascism like a [ __ ]
so much so that they invited the
Hungarian Hitler to this CPAC and then
on stage not only did they they post it
all over the Jumbotron but they said it
out loud we are all domestic terrorists
we see you Leo we [ __ ] see you
we see who you are we know who you are
you piece of [ __ ] and you're a dumb
[ __ ]
you are a dumb [ __ ]
should I keep going on and on about this
we're gonna get the bonehead of the week
here soon let's see
check in let me check in with um Gabe
Sanchez here see oh yeah there we go oh
something's happening here
is Gabe Sanchez going to join us soon
um let's see let me let me let me
message him
me
it um let's see if I can ping Gabe
Sanchez he isn't a private secret bunker
so I don't know if I'll be able to reach
him or not
um but uh
the good news is is that the bone net of
the week our assets the videos the
pictures you know the fancy Graphics
that we have they have appeared they
have emerged
they have emerged
and we are going to do bonehead of the
week in the second hour on Friday as we
do every Friday here
um so hang tight with us I'm sure game
Sanchez Gabe Sanchez will be joining us
soon it's been a long week holy moly
it's been a long week what are you guys
gonna do for Halloween
what are you gonna do for Halloween what
are you dressing up as be careful now be
careful now because you wouldn't want to
confuse you wouldn't want to confuse
a bunch of trumped up white dudes about
your costume you they get really con I
mean they get really confused they get
they have confusing feelings
it really messes with their mind and
their sexual orientation and their
sexuality they get they get all kinds of
weird feelings inside that they've never
felt before so be careful about what
you're dressing up for
especially you know
if it's something of the opposite sex oh
you wouldn't you wouldn't you wouldn't
want
you wouldn't want to dress up
if you're say let's say you're you're
you're you're a good looking gal you
wouldn't want to dress up as I don't
know maybe a cowboy who that might
confuse them that might confuse them
like as Woody from Toy Story you know
what I mean maybe a Woody costume and
and oh if you're if you're a real
masculine man who has big muscles and
you like to tan your balls do not dress
up as a cow girl oh you wouldn't want to
do that it might confuse them they you
know what they might do they might want
to imprison you I mean Matt Walsh told
us I played the video for you just weeks
ago that when someone dresses up when
someone dresses up as something else
that they are not it really confuses a a
white dude it confuses them they don't
know what women are they even wrote a
book so much so that they don't know
what a woman is and it confuses them you
can't dress up as something that you're
not
because it's really confusing and I
don't know what you are so please don't
dress up as a dinosaur or a potato
it confuses me I don't know how to
identify you
so what are you dressing up as Gabe
Sanchez are you are you gonna go
trick-or-treating
no yeah well you got to turn your mic on
first Gabe Sanchez is in a bunker whoa
this looks like a really secret bunker
here
what in the hell is going on he's in
yeah your mic's still not working
I don't know it must it must be that it
must be that deep State internet
connection George isn't uh sending the
full the full signal or something that's
probably what it is uh well here we go
there's Gabe Sanchez
it's like it's report on Halloween
hold on are you dressing so much going
on right now
am I dressing up yeah I thought I would
be uh you know I could be like a a hot
dog
that might confuse them you can't you
man you gotta dress up something that
identifies you as who you really truly
biologically are because if you if you
at all you do not want to confuse people
like uh um Ben Shapiro here your best
buddy have you seen these deep state or
deep fake videos I don't know if they're
defects or they're just really good
edits have you figured that out no I
haven't seen these I haven't even seen
these yet are you serious these are no
wonderful this is wonderful this is Ben
Shapiro at his best I posted this
morning and said that Ben Shapiro is
best some people are like oh you [ __ ]
this is not a man at best but you gotta
listen to what he's saying you really
gotta because so this is real you don't
know this is I I don't know if it's a
really good edit or if it's a really
damn good deep fake I'm not sure yet but
um there's an account that's been
posting these and there was one the
other day with Ben Shapiro in favor of
John Federman and I was like oh this is
fantastic now this morning
coming up on Halloween and how these
little these weak little [ __ ] are
going to be you know confused out there
looking at people in Halloween costumes
because you know they get all kinds of
confused when someone dresses up as
something right you know they don't
think yeah right
something right God forbid right God
forbid they get confused right they get
confused they're like oh my God Gage
Sanchez is a hot dog does that make me
horny that he looks like a hot dog or a
banana oh my God oh God it gives me the
feels he looks he looks so delicious to
see food or is he an actual human I mean
they they really they did just they
can't figure it out but this here this
video here is is Ben Shapiro at his best
let's take a listen today on the bones
we're going to discuss a very common
question can a man be a woman
Dr Levine the government intervening
Senator transgender medicine is a very
complex the answer clearly is yes
Elliott page came out publicly
announcing he is transgender some people
aren't born many women's bodies
women in men's bodies I was trying to
live a life that wasn't me it wasn't my
life
I've known this for quite a while
transgender identity is reality do you
suggest otherwise it's insane at the
nonsense
gender identity is completely separate
from sex
according to biology sex is a spectrum
but typically those who have the X Y
chromosomes are male
those who have X X chromosomes are
female
gender is entirely socially constructed
and thus separate from biology
gender would be all the various feminine
qualities that adhere to Womanhood
the masculine qualities and adhere to
being a male
you might just be a different gender
with different pronouns because your
gender is separate from your sex
the simple reality is that being
transgender is part of the human
condition what's more if gender is a
social construct created by Society all
sexual inequalities could be laid at the
feet of an evil gendered Society
to attend otherwise it was nonsensical
thank you all for being here
and we will March until that darkness is
banished forever
all of our children can stand together
in the sunlight
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen Benjamin Shapiro
we just can't be sure that kids actually
have the gender assigned to them at
Birth the boy is a feminate
she might actually be a girl if a 12
year old says that she is a girl they
want to be treated with empathy and care
you can be a woman in a man's body
sold in the machine
because gender and sex are completely
different the answer for what is man or
what is woman is simple
I Feel Like a Woman therefore I am a
woman
if you're a straight dude and you don't
want to have sex with a trans woman
this makes you gay
[Music]
it's it is it's amazing it's amazing to
know that I mean the material The Source
material that people need to make
whoever made this oh it's beautiful
amazing great job I just took him a long
time because yeah yeah I don't think
it's a deep fake some people think it's
a deep fake but I think it's actually
they're they're they're going in and
they're taking uh [ __ ] that he has read
from you know when he because on his
show he'll be like
um actually actually yeah and he'll read
stuff he'll read stuff that people are
saying and then they just use that as
the clip here so like right I don't
think some of this and maybe some of it
may be a deepake
um but obviously some of it is
the thing is you can I mean obviously
you can deep fake you know face uh you'd
have to have
a
you'd have to teach your
AI to to be really good I mean like
there the other thing too is like if you
have a bunch of source material like
photos and videos and whatnot then you
can easily you can easily do that right
um there are software there is software
that you can use to manipulate and and
create deep fake voices as well
um so that's not outside the pot like
the possibility I know there's examples
of people that have been like oh look
it's George Bush or Obama or you know
Donald Trump or whoever it might be
saying these things and it sounds like
them remember there's also people that
can just impersonate these people you
know though
it doesn't have too much effort well the
the Tom Cruise
um there's a there's a Tom Cruise so
that's right
and the reason that one's easier is
because the actor who's playing him
before they deep fake has a similar like
hairstyle bone structure composition so
it makes right like like he's almost an
impersonator before he's even part of
the deal and that's what he is he is I
mean like he's got the laugh down the
mannerism so that really helps sell
those things but yes this is so what
you're saying in that Tom Cruise one is
the the AI is really only changing parts
of his face to look more like Tom to
look more like Tom Cruise right and it
also changing his voice necessarily no
no no yeah not changing the voice it's
the guy he is totally impersonating him
right it is uh
they I mean because the thing is like
you're using a you're basically you're
setting up a machine that is entirely
dedicated and it can take weeks for it
to learn to be like ah this is the face
like this this is the face like with the
mouth open this the face with the eyes
open closed left right up down all these
things it's Gotta you gotta train this
model right uh to know exactly all the
different you know angles that's why you
don't think it's AI then
I think it's just a really good edit and
this is the account Justin t Brown
um here on yeah this person what they
did is they went through everything
because again like what I was saying in
the beginning was it's amazing how much
Source material you can you can find
from Republicans and other people well I
mean they could take our words here they
can use our words here on this show when
we're mocking them right and I'm mocking
them and they've done those videos about
me on on like YouTube and [ __ ] where
yeah I say things and then they pull
what I because I was mocking I was
mocking the right wing and then they
pull it as if I said it and it's a bad
thing I'm like you get that I okay well
hey you know but you're not picking up
what I'm doing here right right right
right right right you're not you're not
understanding that I'm saying that it's
a bad thing that you're saying by
mocking you and then you're using it to
make me look bad like you're not it's
not the flex they think it is but this
is this is a really good edit like this
is extremely good like I don't know like
we do video editing and I and you're
really good at video editing but this
would take a long this will take a long
time to accomplish this I'm I'm sure
that you know
they worked really hard on this there's
got to be a lot of hours I'm sure if
Justin if Justin t Brown was the one who
made it I'm sure that he had an idea
like he said he said it's him and uh
friends that uh think the brains okay so
yeah if you've got other people then
you're basically what you would be doing
is you're creating a story to say this
is the this is the narrative that Ben
Shapiro has right now which is anti-vis
so how do we make him Pro this and then
they go through and like all right we're
gonna find all the material of him
talking right him saying stuff so we
don't have to show his face so it's
different then we'll use that exact one
where it looks like he's giving this
kind of debunked recession and we can
splice in audio from other recordings
and show photos and show a little
Montage what did you think of the violin
sound that was fantastic right yeah well
I mean you know and then him dancing in
the kitchen and we all know we all know
the gun show oh my God
creepy the creepy manly gun show that he
does for those young people people I
love how they credit Ben Shapiro here
though they give him I mean you know
they give him credit this no this is
your Bureau he is saying those things
right he is saying this one that is
promoting this it's just used it in a
slightly different way now I do want to
point out I I because I actually watched
this a couple times this morning and
while I was watching it I thought you
know what is crazy is when you watch
because there's a visceral reaction that
you kind of have to Ben Shapiro saying
the opposite of what he normally say
says right you know you're like uh [ __ ]
this guy you know what I mean but here's
the thing
is it Ben Shapiro especially the part
where they put they spliced it in with a
crowd uh like a I think it was like a
pride uh prey or Pride day or something
like that where they spliced in a speech
that he gave
um when you watch that part of the video
and you really listen to it and you're
like you know what Ben Shapiro probably
couldn't redeem himself but if he would
have started off on the right foot you
could really see how Ben Shapiro could
have used his voice and his talents
and yeah and really his and really his
intellect and his intelligence to make
sure people in this country understood
equity and equality you're like I
actually can see how that could have
been a thing
and I would I would very much say the
same thing for you know douchebags like
Alex Stein those are people that have
they have a personality and they have a
Charisma to them that can draw people in
right he's very fast talking just like
Ben Shapiro you know you're it's one of
those moments where you like you gotta
you know he's going this fast and then
meanwhile you're like tracking in real
time you're like that's not true that's
not true but he's already you know he he
won't stop and he's another person Alex
Stein Ben Shapiro though you know other
ones like him are
are are awful humans I mean they're
terrible people right let's just call
that what it is but if there were you
know if this was something where they're
actually used uh for good let's say they
could actually be a useful tool to
promote
human rights and the rights of others
however you know it's one of those like
you know the it's like uh
Darth Vader you know and and uh right in
in in
um Anakin Skywalker like there is a
moment in which he could have been good
but then he turned evil and this is one
of those things where it's like you
could have used your influence and your
power and your charisma to be good but
you chose the dark side yeah well and
leading up to Halloween you might choose
to dress as Darth Vader you may choose
you know what maybe I'll just dress up
as bench you know that's that could be
speaking of people who use their talents
our friend Walter
um Walter Masterson
um has joined forces with Lauren Windsor
because Lauren is really they know who
she is now yeah
um they figured out who she I mean I I
think I think she's definitely gonna I
think she's building up her uh
her little like
uh
uh underground undercover right like
Army it's called undercurrent yeah right
that's right exactly it's called
undercurrent you know this um and and
she's been doing a great service to
expose what these people say in private
um for for a long time now now a lot of
people are on to her so she's not as he
she hasn't been able to easily do it now
our friend Walter uh decided to join
forces with her and they're probably
they'll probably because Walter is
easily recognizable I actually funny
part is and he probably won't mind that
I say this I message Walter I'm like
dude so great and he was like you
recognized it as me I'm like the minute
the words came out of your mouth yeah I
could tell it was Walter I'm like how
long Walter will be able to really
accomplish because typically you know
not to reveal what's going on but like
for normal people and like normal
trumpers and whatnot like I mean like
humans like decent yeah yeah yeah well
no not decent these are not decent
humans these are the people that would
go to I don't know uh assault Paul
Pelosi in his home right those are the
type of people and it really very much
aligns with what Paul gosar says here
but um well I mean decent people would
push back on this kind of thing right
decent people would push back and and
any reasonable reasonable and
intellectual politician
would push back on this in the moment
because it is really yeah I mean
honestly it is it is scary the video I'm
about to show you was not released after
this Paul Pelosi event this Paul Pelosi
event just happened last night this
video happened like a week ago
and and it is scary about what what
Walter because it is Walter uh you know
to expose which I think everyone knows
now that it's walted right
um but here's the thing is that Paul
gozar who is one of the ones who has
stoked lies stoked fear and and certain
Americans Hearts
absolutely absolutely is capitulating to
the idea that the Insurrection wasn't
violent and that that the the January 6
insurrectionists are political prisoners
those people who were calling to kill
Nancy Pelosi at the Capitol on the day
of the certification on January 6th
because Trump lost right is the same guy
here who you'll see in the video he is
okay with someone standing in front of
him telling telling him that they are
trying to shoot other human beings
and everything I'm just especially
protecting our Southern border I know as
my family's mass is down in Yuma and we
have the labels
we've shot at them and you you know our
Second Amendment rights to stand around
okay so the person I'm talking to Paul
goes are here is um under current
is uh is Walter Masterson and he says
that he owns a ranch in Yuma and that
and of course he he's making all this up
because he's just looking for the
reaction of how Paul goes our will react
to this
um and he says that we use in our Second
Amendment rights and we're firing at
people they're using their guns to fire
at other human beings on property watch
his reaction here
um you know I'm worried that the
Democrats are gonna send me to jail you
know if I hit one right they have more
rights than we do yeah it's like I can't
shoot at them you know as they cross the
border and stuff but I think I might
have had some I might have hit someone
and I'm like I was distressed about it
for
what a piece of [ __ ] what a piece of
[ __ ] and it's not surprising really that
it's coming from these [ __ ] yeah I
mean they're the you know again you like
you said before like any normal uh just
actual human that cares for others or
just just just
and you know any person that was
actually pro-life
any person from a party that says we're
pro-life
you would think in that moment when
somebody said oh I you know I can't hit
them you know and they go yeah well
they've got more rights than we do okay
that is definitely not the case and then
second is if you were to say oh I was I
was kind of stressed out in like under
duress and all this stuff uh just
because of me you know hitting them
Paul goes our doubles down on the fact
of like yeah that's totally okay you
know that's totally fine that is the
world we live in now and you should be
able to protect yourself
and shoot those people because those
people don't have the same rights and
are not humans but again this whole
pro-life thing they're willing to stand
on this pedestal the Second Amendment
which they don't even really understand
and they want to use an excuse to uh
control Power and you know remove people
who are in their way and those people
are non-white the brown black whoever
might type of person that doesn't look
like them that they don't understand
that they're unwilling to understand and
they don't have empathy toward but we'll
just use as political Pawns
and say ah well if they die they die you
know what they stepped foot on my land
so [ __ ] them right
yeah and that's the I mean that's that's
the that's the inhumane part is They
Don't Really
um Paul goes or doesn't see these people
as humans obviously I mean none of them
do right I mean you whether you've got
Ron DeSantis or Greg Abbott or whoever
it is all these people do not see other
humans even if you are an American
citizen right I'm an American citizen
and I get DMS from people that tell me
that I should go back across the country
this guy's don't this guy's still dming
you I haven't seen a DM lately okay uh I
mean I report I spoke to the FBI
yesterday because it's a hate crime
yeah that you know it's funny when they
come up in the VMS and saying [ __ ] like
that to you that they think they think
that they're they have the freedom to
say that to you directly right and they
have the freedom to be a bigot they
absolutely have the freedom and the
Liberty to be a bigot they have the
freedom and the Liberty to go out
um on a street corner and yell and
scream bigoted things
but you cannot you cannot directly
threaten someone right especially when
you do it in I don't know when you're
under the guise of a hate crime because
you're doing it because of
which the other thing the other thing
that I found funny about that was in in
the line like there's a lot of crazy
stuff this guy says you know like I
should be I'd be grateful to the white
man for the electricity and the computer
that I'm spreading my propaganda on but
the thing that I found the funniest was
he was like you saw us on January 6th
right you saw what we could do right
[ __ ] around and find out you know you
should be great for all the stuff but if
I'm like wait wait wait hold on I
thought you guys said it was black lives
matter and antifa that's right so are
you admitting right now that this is
actually you guys you were the ones at
the Capitol
so well I mean this is not surprising
it's the same [ __ ] people
that would show up at the speaker The
house's residence and what they're
saying now the reporting is that this
guy showed up hoping the speaker of the
house would be it would be there at the
residence and she was not there because
obviously she's working hard in
Washington for the American people they
don't quite understand that she doesn't
fly back to San Francisco every single
night I don't know what the hell the
problem is
um and and we're gonna I know we're
gonna um we're running out of time so I
gotta get the bone in and I really want
to talk about this more but let's do
this let's go to bonetta week we're
going to take a quick break when we come
back we'll be bonehead of the week stick
around we'll be right back right after
these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we're at the bottom of the second hour
but we are in the second hour you know
what that means here on Friday the Tony
Michaels podcast
bonehead
of the week you vote you decide we break
it down for you here on the bonehead of
the week me and my co-host Gabe Sanchez
he's back he's in the Deep State bunker
somewhere but he is back with us he is
back with us
Gabe I'm excited about bonehead of the
week so let's just you know what let's
just get into it let's just let's start
the music
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to bonehead of the week this
week's edition
every single Friday every single Friday
no matter where Gabe Sanchez is at we do
bone end of the week on the Tony
Michaels podcast also replaying on the
Midas touch Network every single Friday
make sure you subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast don't forget to hit
that button and if you're on the mind to
touch Network watching bonehead of the
week right now hit the Subscribe Button
as well because that replay you can also
vote on YouTube on our YouTube channel
the Tony Michaels podcast but Gabe you
can also go over to Twitter as long as
it's still up and running you can go to
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod and you can
vote for bonehead of the week every
single week for every single Friday you
can also download every single bone end
of the week Gabe on Sundays Apple
Spotify Google just go search the Tony
Michaels podcast on any of your favorite
directories and you'll be able to find
bonehead of the week and also why you're
there download every single episode of
our show Monday through Friday two hours
every single weekday
on YouTube Twitter and twitch but you
can download it on all your podcast
directories there if you like this uh
new um banner I got here lock him up
yeah I moved I move my I move my nugs
not drugs and I put the uh I put the
lock him up here behind me those things
on our this thing's on our merch store
it's on
store.vtonymichaels.com while you're
over there checking it out store.the
tonymichaels.com also check out the
Liberty sweaters pull over hoodies and
zip up it's getting cold outside it is
Sanchez it is getting very cold you
better stay warm while you're standing
in line to vote you don't want to get
cold so go to store.thetonymichaels.com
we run on your support and we appreciate
every single bit of it here on the Tony
Michaels podcast Gabe who are our
boneheads this week
oh boy we've got a good collection here
we've got representative Paul gosar yeah
the man that thinks it's okay for people
to shoot uh any migrants that are right
coming across the border
we've got Herschel Walker I paid for
another abortion but most likely I have
other ones that are you know how many is
it how many abortions are there really I
mean you know like I said on the on my
what was that uh segment on this I said
I wouldn't be surprised and this is
after the only the first abortion that
we found out about I said I wouldn't be
surprised if we found out Herschel
Walker paid for more abortions with
other women and then two weeks later we
find out Herschel Walker paid for
another abortion for the woman that he
drove to the clinic
then we also have Senator Lindsey Graham
who seems to be Herschel Walker's
sidekick this week it's kind of gross it
is I mean this whole we'll show clips of
it but this whole like PR kind of let's
fix the problem double down on this
Canada kind of thing I mean they are so
desperate we have we have
um
how many days two weeks less than two
weeks till till the election and I mean
yeah well I guess 11 days yeah right
we're close we are in The Final
Countdown and Republicans are desperate
for that seat and so now they just have
to double down and lead into the fact
that they've got a candidate who has a
history of violence a history of lying
uh you know faking himself to be a
police officer we've got him pain he
continues to do that by the way oh yeah
continues he continues to go out on
stage like they say this is fake but
it's real like I mean you're holding it
I mean it's real as you're holding it
but does he really believe that he's a
police officer I don't know maybe we'll
find out maybe he does I think he does
maybe we'll find out today on on
bonehead of the week so let's go first
to Paul gozar because we were just kind
of watching a video on the podcast of
this guy right um and I want to I want
to go here first because I know this
probably infuriates the absolute hell
out of you um this video here no yeah
we're gonna we're gonna play it here
again
I played it on the podcast but I want to
play it again now um for anyone who
doesn't know Lauren Windsor she does
undercurrent and she goes and she talks
and asks questions to politicians that
are unsuspecting that she's asking them
questions now they believe that she's a
trump supporter or Maga or a right wing
or Republican and she's asking these
questions now she's been
um noticed
um and they've kind of they know who she
is now so she's not as
um easily able to do this anymore so
she's recruited some help here but in
this clip here
um let me take this Banner off here
there we go so you can see the um the uh
uh the words here but listen listen to
this video this is Paul gozar one of the
contestants on bonehead of the week
let's watch
is down in Yuma and we have the labels
okay so the person here talking about
goes are claims he has a ranch in Yuma
and there's the illegals again a key
word
um that that they're using here again it
they're not they're not necessarily
illegal
um just because they're on a piece of
land that's not and because they're
brown but this is the Trope this is the
nonsense that is being pushed by the
right wing and this is what has probably
driven this psychopath who went to the
speaker of the house is residents broken
and and and was looking for Nancy Pelosi
the speaker of the house and ended up
beating her husband with the hammer
let's let's listen to um what Paul gozar
says in reaction
to this person saying what they what
they did to these illegals quote unquote
on their land Jonathan and you know our
Second Amendment rights to stand
background
um you know I'm worried that the
Democrats are going to send me to jail
you know if I hit one right they have
more rights yeah it's like I can't shoot
at them because you know as they cross
the border and stuff I mean I think I
might have hit something I'm gonna hit
someone and I might but I was distressed
about it for a week yeah and so I just
thank you for everything
please
this country needs you shaking his hand
this country needs you and well let me
finish here because it gets worse a
bunch of people that are ready
yeah actually yeah and how [ __ ] gross
is that people ready to go into action I
wonder I wonder Gabe if Paul goes our
when he heard the story about Paul
Pelosi this morning if he was excited oh
I guarantee Paul gosar was [ __ ]
incredibly giddy he was like oh I'm so
excited oh man you know I mean again
this is the Republican party that are
pro-life but are super excited when they
call upon the death of other people
especially lawmakers sitting public
figures they are [ __ ] giddy to the
gills in terms of what possibilities
there are of somebody getting attacked
you find out a guy
in San Francisco shows up with a hammer
to Paul Polo or to the Pelosi household
and says where's Nancy and then you know
beats an assaults uh her husband it's
something that I would hope that
everyone across the board would say yeah
that's not okay and right now what I'm
seeing online
is that there's a lot of people being
like oh this guy David uh well it's
the French way would be the pep right
which is d-e-p-a-p-e is this the suspect
this is the one that they've arrested uh
that was there right so they said now
everyone's online being like oh this guy
is uh a Berkeley resident he's far left
he's this and that like so I I'm already
tracking what's going on the right as of
right now and they're all pushing this
idea that this guy is a leftist he is of
course they have to start that narrative
because they know they know what's real
they know what's real they know the
reality of it and I showed in our show
today a clip from Fox News already
already
capitulating to this this [ __ ] well
I mean the other thing is they're saying
like oh he's a Castro nudist protester
and stuff like it's like okay
I I can't confirm this stuff but sources
are saying that's who the suspect is one
you do realize you can have conservative
views and I mean like I used to live in
San Francisco there were a ton of things
you could do there was the Folsom Street
Fair there was Castro and other areas
where you could be nudists and be
outside and do that stuff you don't have
to be liberal to do those things you can
still have bigoted views and feel like
you want to walk out with a pair of
shoes and nothing else on wait wait are
you telling me that that that
conservatives are allowed to live in San
Francisco Bay area is that what you're
telling me because it sounds like it
sounds like in a country where you're
free to live where you want it feels
like what you're saying is that is that
a conservative a Maga Trump supporter
could live in the Bay Area it almost
yeah it's pretty it's pretty it's pretty
crazy I know you know you know God
forbid there are people who are
conservative that also have these same
type of lifestyle choices for the people
that you want to uh you want to attack
right as a republican they want to
attack these people for doing you know
um
that how they want to live and how they
want to be so it's you know I'm just
I just want to bring that up is right
now they're saying like oh here are
facts about this guy it's like okay yeah
he lives in the Bay Area he's a nudist
that doesn't mean that he is this right
he doesn't mean that you can't be one in
the other the other thing too is like
we've seen people that have gone from
one side to the other side so if you
were pulling up history of someone from
the past that doesn't necessarily
doesn't necessarily mean what they are
today right you could say this person
was an extreme leftist in 1990 to 2000
however and when those things are
documented and then you could say up
until recent let's say in the last six
years this person has changed their ways
still have those lifestyle choices they
can still be that person as far as you
know and what's been documented but they
can also be [ __ ] a no like Nut Job
conspiracy theorist
um still living in the Bay Area right
there are a ton of [ __ ] people who
believe crazy things especially
right-wing ideologies that live in the
Bay Area I mean go to any
you know spoiler for the right wing
people out there but you know CEOs and
other people who run tech companies in
SF
you've got a wide range of people we're
not all left liberal leaning uh marxists
there are a ton of people I've worked
with and also worked for that are very
very much on the right that are very
conservative in their values but they
live in SF there's a lot of money to be
made out here again again Gabe I I want
I want to be careful here because what
you're saying is is that only only
people that not only people who are are
Marxist and leninists and communist can
live in San Francisco is what you're
saying you have you can be something
other than that than
um to live in San Francisco is that what
you're saying is that San Francisco
doesn't have a uh a gate that they're
like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
they're Maga supporter you can't come in
here that's that's not a thing that
exists I mean I just you know I just I
just wanna I just want to bring up the
fact that you know these are things that
uh you know people like like to say that
San Francisco is all crazy liberals uh
that is not the case at all as someone
who who lived in San Francisco for
nearly eight years I can tell you for a
fact
uh working in Tech you meet a lot of
conservative People You Meet A lot of
Libertarians too [ __ ] crazy people
but do you meet do you meet a lot of
boneheads then is that what you oh a ton
of boneheads working at a company and
you know I you know work within products
so you meet a lot of people are like I'm
gonna make decision you're like that's a
very bold assumption you're making about
the user base but we'll try it out you
know like you know what I should do you
know I should I should buy over and an
overpriced
um figure evaluation a social media
company that's what I should do that
sounds like a real bone-headed thing in
Tech okay speaking of another bonehead
Herschel Walker and I don't even I don't
even know if we need to do much on
Hersha Walker to prove why he's a
bonehead I mean you just just like it's
like a clip of Herschel Walker
and I mean he he he's been on his uh
they're you know even if you look at the
little press conference he did with Tom
Cotton and and uh Rick Scott you know
he's doing he's telling these these
stories right these uh these these
stories about a bull and a pastor right
and he's got six six cows that he got
pregnant or whatever and it's really
weird stuff and he looks over the fence
he's like oh there's some other cows
that I want to like get [ __ ] freaky
with
and also by the way at that same at that
same press conference they the song that
introd them in was bad to the bone
which if anyone knows the history behind
that song or just read the lyrics it's
literally about a dude and Bad to the
Bone he's talking about he's
his dick you know and his what his dick
his dick his dick his dick but I like
how you said it I like it yeah it's the
you can't you can't make this stuff up
like the
the ability for them to either double
down on something because they think
it's funny right we're going to make
light of the fact that he lied about
having an abortion but then he's going
to say oh uh he's gonna play this song
about how he's going around spreading
his seed and having sex with people
right which is like the broke a thousand
Hearts right the parallel where I met
you yeah of his life to the song is like
break a thousand more baby right before
I am through so that's that's the words
to the song I mean that's yeah and you
like I said you can't make this stuff up
so at that conference you know he's
outside the bus with them you know
they're giggling and laughing at these
stories that he's telling he's talking
about this cow getting pregnant are
these cows getting pregnant in the bull
scene over you know like
it's always greener on the other side
that's the perception that you have and
then you go over there and then it turns
a bunch of other dudes
homophobic you get homophobic which
again goes back to the whole Matt Walsh
like you see what you think is a woman
right or that looks attractive or
whoever it might be and you go oh man I
got these feelings inside oh and then
it's revealed that maybe they're not
what you think they are and then you're
like oh wait what you know and it's it's
crazy it's almost they think too much
about the dick okay they think way too
much about it like if you were too
focused on that kind of thing for normal
society to operate right it's like be
more really too focused on genitalia you
would think that life is already crazy
enough you've got to worry about your
family your expenses the food and you
know things you put on the table you
would think that those would be more
important also having Representatives
that rep that you know lawmakers that
represent you as a constituent to
actually do something that actually you
do something they care for you that
actually want the well-being of the
community you would think that those
things would be important right but
instead they care about governing the
same people who say I want small
government I don't want an overreaching
government they're the same people that
say oh yeah the medical choices that you
make as a woman should be between you
your doctor and your local politician
right which is
insane I've never I've never I couldn't
think of a way to say this this morning
because I was like I've never like in my
lifetime in my entire lifetime I've been
here almost 40 years and I'm like I've
never heard ever before
someone suggests that the mayor or like
a councilman should be in the doctor's
office with you when you're talking
about a medical procedure like what the
[ __ ] are you what the hell like what
what planet are you people on anymore
like how did you get so far down this
road off the track so much that you're
telling people what you a Senate
candidate a United States Senate
candidate who who honestly has a huge
microphone I mean he doesn't live in the
state that he's running and he's a
carpet bagger and he's a dual citizen
he's a liar he's a snake oil salesman
but he actually stands on stage and says
that local politicians should be helping
you make your medical decision it's a
weird ass [ __ ] and I've never heard it
before in my mind Dr Dr Oz a quack
doctor is yeah is telling people that
those those are the people that should
be involved in your body right but these
are the people running for Senate though
like Christian Walker now Herschel
Walker
for everyone who doesn't know the new
news is that Herschel Walker has paid
for a second abortion now I think the
most significant um part of this story
is um that uh Allred attorney all red
actually gave her a press conference and
we might play it here but I got a more
important video I want you to see about
Herschel Walker
um
Allred said that not only Gabe did
Herschel Walker pay for this abortion
the woman he this is like in 1993 took
the woman to the clinic
the woman decided not
she chose not to have an abortion she
had the choice and she chose not to
Herschel Walker then coerced her back to
the clinic made her go inside and he
waited in the parking lot until she had
an abortion so not only is Herschel
Walker paying for abortions he has a
history of forcing a woman to have
abortion which is not surprising
honestly because there is no principle
with this pro-life stuff these forced
birthers when you will force a woman to
have a baby even if their life or a
little girl has been raped by their
uncle or their dad if you will be if you
will force a woman or a little girl to
have a baby you definitely definitely a
hundred percent will force someone that
you want to have an abortion to have an
abortion which is [ __ ] it's just
right down the alley of these [ __ ]
bashes but I want to play a video here
this is my good friend in a tick tocker
and Thomas the villain bishop and he
lays out who Herschel Walker is in this
video in three minutes and it is
absolute perfection
of how he describes it and then when we
go to the bonehead of the week I want to
tell you how these things connect let's
watch
so USA Today
put out an opinion piece
and it's basically something I've been
saying all along
about Herschel Walker
you see in the annals of the
Republican brain
Herschel Walker is the perfect
representation for black people
without question
he is every stereotype that we have been
called for 40 50 60 [ __ ] years
every single one
absentee father check
abusive
check
illiterate
check
athletic
check
will listen to
what his Masters say
check
he's a perfect representation
and sadly
he might just win
he might just win
you see
black men like Fred Hampton and Huey P
Newton and Malcolm X and Martin Luther
King
at no point would they do the step and
fetch it for
for American society they weren't going
to do it
too much pride too much dignity too much
manliness for that to happen
but the racist tropes never went away
they never did we never confronted them
unless we confronted them in the black
community but we never confronted them
Nationwide society-wide
so they persisted
and to look at someone like Rafael
Warnock
who embodies the spirit of the Fred
Hamptons the Malcolm X's the Martin
Luther Kings
well how do you beat that
you beat it by putting somebody's so
polar opposite yet so acceptable because
he's under your banner that he might
just win
and they found it
lusting after white women check
he is everything we have ever been
called in society
I keep saying all along
if they find a picture of Herschel
Walker eating Chicken and watermelon you
will have inward bingo
and sadly he might win
so when people start talking to me about
how much we progressed as a society the
only thing I must say from this point
forward is look at Herschel Walker and
tell me you still believe that
I I I he just might win he just might
win and he could win and that's the
saddest part about this video is the
truth and the matter that we actually
are in a position where and Thomas lays
it out perfectly here that we have a
candidate of Herschel Walker in this
position where he could be elected as a
United States senator now I'm very
competent in fact that the people of
Georgia will have levelhead and they
will go and they will make sure that
Herschel Walker is not anywhere near
making decisions for us as a people
right and but I think the way that
Thomas lays it out here is
um it really is kind of dark to be quite
honest with you but it's the truth it's
the truth it's the truth that maybe
maybe not a lot of people want to admit
especially white people but it's the
[ __ ] truth right it's the truth and
if you don't like it if it gives you a
weird feeling inside
it's because it's the truth so I I think
um Thomas for giving us that video I
played it earlier on this week and
everyone really liked it and I would I
mean there's been there's a lot in you
know leading up to the midterms you know
there's a question of like is all this
kind of in place like the things that
are happening outside of this right
you've got Twitter and it's like oh is
this a distraction obviously you've got
other things like Kanye West I think
this directly ties in with stuff like
Kanye West which is creating a
normalization of anti-blackness which
also leads into
anti-Semitism right and making that
perfectly okay right there's always a
canary in the coal mine there's always
going to be something that shows you an
early indication that things are kind of
on the rise in terms of this type of
villainous activity and behavior and
this is something where you say oh well
you know it's totally okay you know
obviously people are gonna be like oh
I've got that one black friend or we've
got this one guy who's running for
office who's black like how can you tell
me there's not uh oppression or there's
not racism you know in this country I
can tell you firsthand I get messages
not as bad as things that other people
get obviously I don't have people
showing up to my house with a hammer or
I've got you know other people that are
threatening other people because of the
way that they look or the things that
they believe in or whatever it might be
but that is that's the party that's the
party right there and there are a few
people within the Republican party that
send our thoughts and prayers obviously
uh uh but it doesn't mean [ __ ] when
those are the same people that are
sending thoughts and prayers when
students and children are just Slaughter
right by easily accessible guns this is
a party that wants to Gaslight and
scapegoat and victim blame and and throw
the the responsibility on someone else
and say oh there's nothing we can do
about it
when we turn a blind eye and we don't
address these things and we don't you
know shine light on these things then
what we find ourselves is a society that
is willing to say yeah that's okay that
that one group that is marginalized
is okay being you know degraded or
insulted or assaulted in any way
and that is the Republican party right
they might say one thing but behind
closed doors they're saying a completely
different thing which is yeah we're okay
being racist and bigots and anti-semites
and you know transphobic and homophobic
and all of these things
and that is what the Republican party is
and that is what mag is that is what
trumpism is and that's what we're up
against when we go to the ballot on
November 8th you know if you can vote
now vote now I mean remember that do not
look at the polls do not take this
defeatist attitude do not take this oh
we're we're totally okay right now
because I live in a blue state or
whatever you know it's everything down
as you say to the [ __ ] dog catcher
that's right these are the positions
that are up for grabs and the ones that
these people start low and build their
way up right so they're building their
political clout by starting at a low
position and then who knows the next
time they run it could be for a U.S
representative or state position then it
could be a U.S senator these are things
that we have to stop in its tracks right
now and if we don't then we're gonna
find more of this normalization oh it's
totally okay that a political candidate
said these anti-semitic things right or
said these racists
exactly and the thing is
right like he apologized to the Jewish
Community I would I'm everyone is still
waiting for him to apologize to the
black community he said thing years ago
like slavery was a choice and Harriet
Tubman didn't free the slaves and all
these things and he has not apologized
to a community that has been
marginalized and has been oppressed for
so long right it really does show you
the fact that the Republicans are
unwilling to speak out against the
things that he said because like oh
great he's a vessel to normalize this
type of rhetoric and if he says it then
it's fine we've got a group of people
that now can then say well if he said it
then we can say it and you let the
boogeyman out of the closet and you
can't put him back in right that's the
that's the situation we're in right now
well and I'll tell you that leads me to
the DM the dishonorable mention because
Steve scalise this morning is saying out
loud and he's saying what he wants right
right because that he's a dishonorable
mention this morning because Steve
scalise is saying oh he sees the country
going in the way of Italy which is right
wing which if you go look at Italy and
you look at the facts the reason why
Italy went right wing is because the
generic ballot the independence the
moderates that we think of here didn't
participate and in their democracy there
so here in the United States
if the if the independence if the
moderates if everyone does not
participate in their democracy and does
not lean in to their democracy yes we
may it is super important if you can
vote to go vote not just not just on the
day but if you can vote early and it's
more important Gabe now than ever to not
just see your ballot is your right it is
your right to engage in your democracy
you must encourage three people to go
vote right you must get those three
people to encourage three more people
right that is how and and you do that by
engaging maybe it's just pulling up the
video I just showed you of Thomas
telling you what is the truth about
Herschel Walker and not not about the
truth the Herschel Walker as in Herschel
Walker shouldn't be United States
Senator the truth about the people who
are supporting him right that is the
Stark thing that I think Thomas lays out
so well in that video is the truth about
it because Steve scalise our
dishonorable mentioned today
wants the right wing here they want an
authoritarian State they want to be able
to tell you that you can't get an
abortion and that you have to get an
abortion just like Herschel Walker
because folks they're supporting that
candidate that's their guy that's their
[ __ ] guy right now
because you you know there's I just want
to bring up this comment because he's
been he's been absent from the show oh
really uh who do we have with us fake
game oh has has made an appearance back
after he gets suspended I don't know
yeah it could have been I don't know I
just remembered the last time we saw him
was after uh Texas Paul ripped him a new
one
and it I don't know if he got suspended
or he kind of you know tucked tail and
ran away but since he hasn't been here
right he's gonna make a comment here
that says in order for white supremacy
to succeed is you to believe you are
inferior are any of you inferior to
anybody
I don't believe that I am inferior to
anybody however I have people on a
roughly daily basis that send me
messages that tell me I am
now since you weren't here just to fill
you in fake Gabe I got some messages
from a white supremacist that told me to
go back across the country to where I
came from to go to my [ __ ] Nation on
my dirty ass floor in Mexico like all
the other Mexicans in Venezuelans where
were you born Gabe where were you born I
was born here in the United States oh
okay I'm just pretty crazy pretty crazy
your dad's from Mexico though a
beautiful day yeah my dad is from Mexico
I have family there right but I was born
I'm a citizen and the other Jeremy
Johnson on here wants me to show my
papers I I didn't know that we were
dealing with the Gestapo right
but
fake Gabe hasn't been here so just to
give you a background I got a message on
Instagram uh this guy telling me that I
you know [ __ ] around find out the white
man you should be grateful uh he's gonna
come and you know take over and take
control if you don't know what's good
for you basically threatening me it's a
hate crime uh reported spoke to the FBI
yesterday so when somebody tells me oh
white supremacy on success if you
believe you're in fear that is not true
I don't believe that I'm inferior I
believe that we're all equal now I do
believe there is a class as society that
we live in where people have more power
but do I believe that we're all equal as
a human to human yes I do because that
is what this country was founded on
right the pursuit of happiness Liberty
Justice and the fact that we are all
equal the country has a past that is
pretty messy and terrible and we're we
are some of it's pretty gross let's say
it is pretty gross but we have done we
are you know
we are moving forward you know despite
some people like white supremacists and
Republicans who want to regress our
country back to when women didn't have
the right to vote or when uh the black
community didn't have the right to vote
or when you know like everything that is
that is pro-white are these ideologies
that they want so when somebody tells me
that are you inferior to anybody else I
don't believe I am however you have
people within the Republican party that
support Trump and other in this Maga
ideology that do believe they're better
they do believe because they're white
that they are superior to me and that I
am inferior to them just because of my
last name and make the assumption that
I'm not a legal citizen in this country
so when I see stuff like this from fake
Gabe you know I'm glad to see that
you're back uh because we love that you
engage with the show and that you expose
your dumb
[ __ ] we'll call it but copy machine
the Chinese but when I see stuff like
this I just want to call it out because
it is it is uh ignorant it is dumb
moronic uh and it's exactly what the
white supremacists want by the way right
it's exactly what the white supremacists
want it's for fake Gabe and people like
fake Gabe and really more than anything
people like Herschel Walker Candice
Owens Kanye West and real Gabe here they
they want them to believe this [ __ ] this
garbage because because that that is how
they win but we must not let them win we
must not let them win no matter how much
they claim to be for free speech and all
this stuff and they they claim to be for
this or for that and inferior this and
Superior that right because game I got a
story for you here on the um on the
alpha because someone got Alpha cuck of
the week you know we do dishonorable
mention and we have the alpha cook and
the alpha [ __ ] of the week is Elon Musk
and we know the Note news about Elon
Musk but I want to show you why he got
cucked by a cat turd
[Laughter]
as the first order of business at
Twitter he got cucked by a catcher
listen to this
um this account says uh now this name of
this account is this machine kills
bashes imagine spending 44 billion
dollars to be at the behest of someone
called captured Elon Musk is such a
loser this is [ __ ] real I'm not
making this [ __ ] up this tweet yeah you
can go find this tweet I double checked
I even I even took a screenshot of this
because remember if anyone uh I called
it out in in the last what was that on
the January 6th day nine but also if you
just go look for cat turd 2 and just put
in quotes busted or LOL busted
you will find that this account still
has it up quote tweeted another account
who uh who took a screenshot of Nancy
Pelosi on the phone January 6 when she's
calling for backup to help control the
capital right the phone is black because
you mean the screen the screen is blank
right this is why she's holding it to
her face exactly because the phone you
know this spoiler alert has what's
called a proximity sensor right and just
in layman's terms it's a sensor this
little sensor that detects if there's an
object in front of it right and it'll
turn the screen black so that it doesn't
waste the battery right so we reduce
battery consumption because when things
are on they use power oh and also if
it's on then you could actually
accidentally touch the screen so well
you mean you're telling what I just want
to make sure that I understand
technology because we're about to talk
to about the person who supposedly
invented the electric car which he did
not but he supposedly you're telling me
that when I hold a touch screen phone to
my face case if my skin touches it it
could actually activate the buttons on
the touch screen is that what you're
telling me because it seems like that
would almost be I don't know a feature
of a smartphone that when you put it to
your face that it would turn the screen
off that way you don't inadvertently
touch it with your face you don't send a
message you don't add a call you don't
end the call hang up yeah it's kind of
weird kind of stuff it's kind of crazy
because remember it's complicated
tactile buttons right we moved from flip
phones to do you think smartphones do
you think cat turd has like a like a
Blackberry do you remember blackberries
are the buttons they have buttons on it
yeah well that yeah they they didn't
have buttons you know I don't know maybe
they're still using a Palm Pilot with a
little silence maybe that's it but I I'm
serious we have to talk about the count
cat turd here on the bone end of the
week believe it or not
he tweets the cat turd account tweets
report
oh my God day one of Elon Musk owning
Twitter I'll be doing this every day to
see if anything changes
as of now I'm still Shadow banned
ghostban search band and Twitter removed
1200 followers today as usual whatever
the hell that means nothing has changed
I'll report again tomorrow so it's a
good thing that cat turd is staying on
top of this because look here Elon Musk
responds now um it was within 12 hours
so you know I mean he's not right on
he's got a lot of other things to do he
had to fire the CEO he had to fire the
CFO he had to get there he had to fire
the you know legal execs he had to get
those people out well yeah I mean how it
how how is how is he literally going to
destroy Twitter without doing all that I
mean right he's here to destroy Twitter
so Elon Musk literally
this is [ __ ] real I am not making
this up I had to double check this [ __ ]
I had to make sure it was real I sent it
to Gabe to make sure he could verify it
so we weren't [ __ ] up here on the
bone end of the week and saying
something that wasn't real this is
[ __ ] real Elon Musk replied to the
account captured
as much as it hurts me to say that
sentence and he replied with this I will
be digging in more today
he literally sent a message to an
account on Twitter called cat turd who
likely if it is a cat which I don't know
how this person identifies but if they
are a cat who uses a litter box they
literally would be digging in the litter
box he sends them a message I will be
digging in more today into Why cat turd
who gives a [ __ ] about this really but
apparently it really does just like the
the caption said it really does show you
that a guy is willing to pay 44 or get a
group of people and himself to purchase
a company for 44 billion dollars which
started off as a joke poll he paid over
the amount of what the market was
offering right in terms of what it was
actually valued in the stock market he
did 5420 which equaled out to 44 billion
and some change he buys this thing and
what is he doing as Chief [ __ ] I mean
twit uh what is he doing he is playing
customer service representative he is a
he is taking personal requests to look
into this which by the way I also want
to I want to emphasize he's complaining
about losing 1200 followers I lost 200
today and over the course of three
months like
it's Twitter purging out Bots I've lost
probably a thousand or so people over
the last month when they've been doing
these things where like oh I wake up and
I lost 200 I lose 100 I lose 300 I lose
200.
like I said I've lost about a thousand
now [ __ ] though yeah it's like that's
what it does right you know you've got
Elon complaining about Bots and not
wanting to to actually go into the deal
in July because you're like oh well yeah
he's trying to he he tried everything he
possibly could right up till last minute
yesterday to get out and they're like no
we you need to buy it you signed a
contract right it's your fault you
didn't read it or and it's your fault
that you didn't put any other
stipulations in it you have to now buy
it so now you've got captured responding
to other people's messages and goes I've
now gained seven thousand followers
since last night when I tweeted that
things are definitely changing and it's
glorious okay so I want to point out
that already
Elon Musk hasn't owned this [ __ ]
for more than 24 hours and here we are
on the internet having to talk about how
this thing has went to the litter box
literally yeah because of a count called
cat turd this this is absolutely in the
Wheelhouse of these end cells of these
morons because literally as funny and
crazy as it is that the new CEO the new
owner whatever the hell he is what the
chief [ __ ] as you called him who now
owns Twitter who he literally the reason
why he's tweeting at cat turd is the
same reason why he had to buy Twitter
right against the same reason that he
had to buy Twitter it's the same stupid
[ __ ] like oh my God man you can't make
this [ __ ] up and don't live in such a we
didn't live in such a weird time right
and also
what I find funny is that he tweeted
that uh or they I don't know who Kat
turd is I think it's a dude because he
has a show he's like a podcast Marjorie
Taylor who has actually been on the the
cat turd show I think gotcha so if you
look at the look at the time stamp if
you go back to that one oh yeah yeah let
me let me see if I can go back so just
to give everyone an understanding of how
close these tweets are all right so this
says 703 am your time right now go up to
elon's response and click into that so
703 am this is 6 41. that's my time I'm
in central yeah yeah so from 703 to 641
if we do the math here we're talking 22
minutes 22 minutes from uh Elon saying
I'm gonna look more into this today
and Cat turd 2 saying well since last
night tweeting that I've gained 7 000
followers the two are not connected the
two are not in any way connected the
reason that cat turd is Shadow band and
search band and all these oh it's
because you [ __ ] spread conspiracy
theories and right-wing ideologies that
are just inherently misinformation and
elon's gonna fix that today right he's
gonna fix that today it's not uh
Twitter's fault that people report you
for misinformation right and spreading
conspiracy theories when you do that
it's like you know you're getting
strikes against your account to say well
this person has been dinged for this and
ding for this and maybe we should not
promote that as much anymore wait you
mean there's an algorithm that detects
all these things is that what you're
telling me you know what you're saying
come on is that why they're purging Bots
is because the algorithm figures out who
the Bots are this is this is all just it
I can't even believe that we're talking
about can't turd yeah um and there's a
lot of reasons why 7 000 followers
though it has not been here you know
what actually let me just go check on
this oh you're gonna check the account
to see how many and the followers are
actually fake so while you're doing that
while you're doing that I want to go
back to
um the bonehead of the week candidates
because we have Paul goes our Herschel
Walker and Lindsey Graham yeah now
obviously we know who the winner is now
because of who we talked about and the
progression of the bone end of the week
I am actually surprised that they voted
for Lindsey Graham Gabe Sanchez yeah I
really felt like I really felt like it
was gonna be Herschel Walker I thought
what happened too it was on YouTube
YouTube was usually things align about
right on between Twitter and YouTube the
polls kind of mirror each other because
you can vote for bone end of the week on
Twitter or you can vote on YouTube I
will admit last night when I went to
because Gabe puts it on Twitter and he
sends it to me because he he ultimately
chooses who is on book I I kind of help
but Gabe is ultimately the chief of the
bonehead of the week yeah so Chief
bonehead right he's Chief bonehead not
Chief [ __ ] Chief bonehead here at bone
of the week and he sends me the poll
when he posted and then I am responsible
or as last night I'm irresponsible of
making sure I get some on YouTube now I
copied it and I went to my app to add it
as a post because I use my cell phone
because it's the easiest quickest way to
get the poll up on there
so I was using my cell phone and as I
was copying it and I went to the post
and YouTube and I was um laying out the
choices in the poll someone called me
and when I got the phone call I answered
the phone call and never went back so I
wait when you when you took the phone
call did the screen turn black well you
know I don't want to I don't want to
spread any kind of conspiracy theories
around man how technology works I don't
want to spread it I don't know man that
sounds because basically what would
happen is if you took it you took the
phone call you could have accidentally
posted something oh my YouTube oh my God
you know what I you know what I bet it's
that technology that made sure that that
poll did not go out last night that it
went out really early this morning
because when I woke up this morning
I checked my phone and like oh [ __ ] the
bonehead of the weak Bowl I don't
remember pushing go I went in and I had
to finish it I had to put two more
choices in and then and then send it but
everyone voted but they voted in a way
that we didn't imagine right so it was
the it was the votes on YouTube you know
they what'd you find on this counter to
count by the way what did you find on
this right so I wanted to double check I
haven't checked the actual uh Bots part
but I did double check the claim of I
got seven seven thousand followers so
here
here's the thing I'm looking at a a
breakdown I mean we can also here if we
can put it up on the screen if you want
to just so people are like oh you know
figure even Gary Johnson are going to
say you guys are fake news fake even
though we're not the news
here this is the links
okay
it's free it basically just tracks
everyone's account on YouTube Twitter
Tick Tock uh Instagram anything you can
think of all right okay here we go if
you scroll down
so this is cat turd 2.
capture two why is it catford too
because I guess cat turd one no I think
it got it got suspended
for probably spreading misinformation
why wouldn't why wouldn't cat turn two
asked to have cat turn one unbanned I
mean wouldn't you you know it's one of
those who I mean if you had the ear of
Elon mus total Grade B what does that
mean I don't know it just means based on
all these different factors that's the
like oh your your social media kind of
Greater oh it's based on your followers
who you follow how many pretty average
pretty average yeah yeah okay um so if
you scroll down and we keep going here
yeah keep going keep going keep going
there we go okay right here no no go up
up up up up up up up up to where the yep
the table is right here okay so what
you're gonna see here is this shows you
the date
and also the followers who they follow
who follows them the tweets that they
send and they show you basically what
the growth or loss is the gain or losses
on your account it doesn't look like 7
000 is the number I'm not seeing a loss
of 1200 I'm not seeing a gain of seven
thousand even if guys this we're gonna
do some simple math here even if you
said I lost 1200 but I gained 7 000 the
Delta between the two would be fifty
eight hundred correct today 10 28. right
so that's from yesterday you know
midnight up until today uh but keep it
even if you add these two figures
together that's not even closest and
again even if you were to subtract 7 000
from 1200 you get fifty eight hundred
that I'm not seeing 5800 even I know
it's I know what's going on I know
what's going on here if I will yeah
it's an account called captured and
we're expecting it to know how math
Works hmm I mean that could be where
we're going
it could be where we're going wrong here
is it's it's an account called cat turd
who has the attention of the chief [ __ ]
Elon Musk
and we're expecting it to know how math
works I think that's where we're really
going wrong it's almost as if we're
assuming there's logic within a group of
people who don't understand how I don't
know a phone works right I think that's
where we're at I think that's where
we're at I think we're red
it is it's I did oh I did by the way I
looked up the fake follower account and
captured 2 has they've got a total about
844 000 followers their percentage of
fake followers that are like you know
inactive bot users and such are 28
percent
so 28 whoo whoosh whoosh whoosh whoosh
okay well let's um let's go back to the
the bonehead poll here let's get to the
bonehead of the week we are over on time
on the podcast but we don't care we're
gonna finish out the bone end of the
week here because we have a special
bonehead for you
he's appeared on the bonehead of the
week several times
um he is a favorite here at bonehead of
the week Senator Lindsey Graham is the
bonehead of the week
um he and and great fashion lady G has
worked his way up to the top of the
bonehead totem pole here for bone net of
the week but Gabe why is he the bonehead
of the week what did he exactly do
exactly well you know there's a there's
a through line right every week There's
a through line through it's almost like
the boneheads are always connected
they're they're connected in some way
and it's almost like they're all
Republican or Maga I don't yeah and I
saw and I saw someone on in the comments
I just want to address it really quickly
they said uh you know instead of instead
of focusing on cat turd talk about these
you know go volunteer I agree 100 go
volunteer go to the polls get your
friends you know voted without what I
will call her right now is if anyone's
seen the movie pay it forward let's vote
It Forward right you get three people
they get three people it's an it's an
exponential effect
I think if you can phone bank do it if
you can volunteer do it go to the polls
go vote ignoring the polls do not look
at well there's only one poll that
matters right and I know we want to talk
about bonehead the weak pull but the one
poll that actually matters in this
country is the one that's going to
happen on November 8th so I I appreciate
the person bringing it up because I do
want to call attention and all of these
things are connected right these
accounts are connected and promoting
these people like Lindsey Graham and
Herschel Walker to run for office that
they are trying to support these are the
people that are doing anything they can
to put these types of people these
fascists these people who want to take
away your rights who want to be
Hypocrites in office these are the
people that are running for office that
mean we need to make sure are not in
office right these I wanna you know I'm
I'm a patriot and I care for my freedom
and my Liberty and this and that no
these people again rights of me not for
thee they don't care about you they
don't care about anything if you look at
the past few months the only people that
have been passing legislation that has
been actually for the constituents and
for the American people are the
Democratic party whether it's the
inflation reduction act or the chips act
or you know helping reduce uh child
poverty and you know uh helping to fund
school lunches helping to make sure that
America is actually back on track right
like GDP numbers came out the other day
they were good reducing inflation is
good reducing gas prices you know all of
these things that Republicans complain
about they are unwilling to actually
come to the table and help out with
right and all of the people that are
running all the people that the
Republican Party are pushing especially
like Lindsey Graham and that's why he
found himself on bonehead of the week
they're pushing these candidates who are
just puppets they're just puppets doing
just pushing themselves as a it's
another seat that can add a vote against
the the
um the things that would actually help
this country and this and this video
shows that puppetry I mean perfectly it
shows that and you know what I'm just
thinking about that what if Lindsey
Graham is captured I'm just saying what
if it's a soccer puppet account I don't
know I don't know I mean I could be
listen Gabe is right on this cat turd
may sound funny and that that dialogue
may be like what does that have to do
with the election it has everything to
do with it because they love a cat turd
loves to push videos like this in a way
that they want to perpetuate what
happens in this video and before I play
it I want to say we watched the video
from Thomas describe who Herschel Walker
is
and what he represents
and this video is another [ __ ] check
mark on the box where Lindsey Graham a
white Southern man gets to speak for
Herschel Walker the black man in this
video literally this is the Trope and
this is the thing that Thomas was
talking about in that video this checks
another one of those boxes watch this
clip it's not that long but this is why
to Me Lindsey Graham has been into the
week but they're scared to death of
Herschel Walker because if Herschel
Walker becomes a republican maybe every
other young child in America of color
might want to be a republican that's
what they're trying to do don't let them
get away with it team herschel.com I
want the biggest night for the Herschel
Walker campaign to be tonight
he is almost as red as that Background
by the way like he is right when you
talk about puppetry there holy Jesus
this guy is off the [ __ ] rails
Lindsey Graham is spewing right instead
of saying hey we should come together
and we should work together obviously
it's very hard when one side is
unwilling promotes violence promotes
conspiracy theories promotes a coup an
overthrowing of a government wants to
remove rights uh wants to uh hang a vice
president hang a vice president Speaker
of the House wants to take away the the
the rights of women to choose what they
can and can't do with their own body
right this is a group that says limited
government I don't want an overreaching
government I want my body my choice
but at this in our you know pro-life and
we're we're pro this and pro that no
they are not they are pro themselves
they are pro-selfish that is what they
are they don't care about you they they
are using everyone they are using
Herschel Walker as a puppet as a talking
point as a another seat in the Senate so
they can have majority when it comes to
voting on something that would actually
help you and me and everyone else in
this country is this the type of person
either of these two people these are the
type of people when you're cut when your
state is is experiencing a natural
disaster
or is experiencing some other atrocity
that's happening you want these two
people saying you know what we could do
something to help you right now but
we're not we could be sending you Aid
and assistance when your state is
experiencing a hurricane or or any other
other kind of uh uh event but instead we
won't do that but when our state is
experiencing that we will 100 vote for
that socialism and use that Federal
taxpayer money to help us but not you
but not you well they're definitely
Hypocrites and they're definitely
boneheads and Lindsey Graham this this
pause here on this video is perfect it
is look at that beauty oh my God you've
got hostel Walker totally clueless
Lindsey Graham just like he is hitting a
boiling point face is getting red this
the way in which he directs his anger
yells at Herschel Walker Herschel Walker
just sits there like I'm just here I
don't I was just told to be here at this
time and then it's yelling to be like I
want everyone out voting for team
Herschel I want this and I want that I
want it's like dude calm down take a
[ __ ] chill pill like maybe take a
Xanax or something because you need to
[ __ ] just chill let me ask you let me
ask you let me ask you
do you think Herschel Walker's sitting
here thinking is this is this the point
where I pull out the badge is this it is
this yeah do I need to tell people I'll
check their their papers is this right
is this the part where I pull out my
prop badge is this the part he's not
sure exactly where he's just like is it
now like he's thinking inside his
internal dialogues like I'm not sure
when to pull it out but I know I got to
get my fake badge yeah at some point
he's like I'm I gotta show right and
they're like no keep it don't I told you
not to bring that thing right and again
one of those things like we have to
control this guy from what he says
because if you were to leave Herschel
Walker to his own kind of free will he
would say something like he's done in
the past that is so incredibly dumb and
outrageous and then the Republican Party
says oh you know who you need we need
Tom Cotton a white guy right Rick Scott
a white guy we need Lindsey Graham A
white guy we need Donald Trump a white
guy we need all these white people right
to come forward and talk for him right
right that's the Trope that's what is
that's what Thomas was talking about in
the video this black guy running for
office said some stuff he's in a bit of
a jam who's gonna fix it and tell the
people and speak on his behalf it's
going to be a white guy you should thank
the white man right Gabe isn't that what
they're telling you yes that's what a
lot of people tell me that's why Lindsey
Graham is the bonehead of the week this
week and really I mean he's pretty much
a bonehead as the rest of these are
every single week so let's give lady G
his dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh Lindsey Graham lady G you are a
bonehead as you will be now and forever
you are a bonehead and a bonehead of the
week this week thanks for joining us for
bone of the week this Edition you can
watch bonehead of the week every single
Friday on the Tony Michaels podcast in
the second hour or of the replay here on
the Midas touch Network don't forget if
you're on the minus touch Network to hit
that subscribe button it's really easy
real easy Gabe and if you want to vote
for bone end of the week just go over
and follow our show our channel the Tony
Michaels podcast you can vote on YouTube
there as long as I get it up in time and
you can also vote on Twitter so go
follow us at Tony Michael's pod that is
where you vote for voting of the week
you can also download every single
episode of our podcast and bonehead of
the week on on Sunday we post bonehead
of the week on Apple Spotify Google your
favorite directories make sure while
you're subscribing to the Tony Michaels
podcast to listen the bonehead of the
week make sure you're leaving us a great
review while you're subscribing and
don't forget don't forget to stay warm
out there why you're standing in line
voting go to store.dtonymichaels.com
that's store.the tonymichaels.com and
grab your Liberty sweatshirts pull over
hoodies and zip up hoodies
it's gonna be cold it's getting cold
outside and make sure you stay warm just
go to
store.thedonymichaels.com store that's
the attorney michaels.com this has been
another great edition of bone net of the
week everyone if you're on the podcast
stick around we got a few announcements
but if you're on the Midas touch Channel
we will see you next week this has been
bonehead of the week
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we're over 30 minutes
uh these people are gonna think we're
gonna start doing three hours every day
if we're not careful they're gonna
expect it uh everyone thanks for joining
us here at the Tony Michaels podcast
thanks for sticking around for Bona of
the week we're glad to have you back
here today today Gabe even though you're
in some kind of undisclosed deep space
CIA location who knows maybe I'm going
to go visit Elon Musk at Twitter are you
gonna go try to get a job are you
leaving the Tony Michaels podcast no I
didn't I did I did joke with Tony last
night I was like hey maybe I should go
just work for Twitter now wouldn't that
be hilarious that would it would be
pretty funny [ __ ] I do know you could
do it like while you're working you
could do the show I don't know maybe
maybe yeah I do I do know for a fact
because I've got I've got friends who
work at Twitter and other tech companies
in SF because again no no don't don't
tell secrets like CIA secrets and stuff
you can't tell those kind of Secrets
here uh I do know I do know yeah
um that right now there are people that
are leaving Twitter because like I'm not
gonna [ __ ] deal with this [ __ ] right
you know well but how about how would
you really know when you're gonna go
like why wouldn't you just go on your
own terms I mean that's kind of right so
some people are leaving on their own
terms a lot of these tech companies like
Facebook and other ones are are looking
and swooping in and taking Talent from
Twitter right now because there is a
desire for people to get out of that
company so like oh great I'll do it
right and obviously that does help Elon
Musk because elon's like I'm doing a
psyop right now and I say I'm gonna
remove 75 of the people that are here
right which
a global company for how many different
logistical operations are happening at
one time for that company moderation uh
design
uh customer service which Elon seems to
be doing that personally for cat turd uh
you you have all these positions right
that take a there's a lot of management
people that are executing and people
that are supporting those decisions
right
uh you want to take away 75 percent
that's not a realistic thing and what
he's doing is a psyop which is to get
people believing that he's going to come
and he's going to move these people
obviously the first he's like CEO and
CFO you're out the first day people are
like oh they got owned it's like dude
I'm pretty sure their packages on the
way out were pretty nice they've also
got stock options and are getting paid
out of a 44 billion dollar amount that
was over valuation yeah exactly so when
all these people on the right wing are
like oh man these guys got [ __ ] owned
by the [ __ ] troll King it's like do
you know how much money they made how
much money okay Elon got drenched in
this deal okay so here's what I'll tell
you the craziest part to me is that most
of these Elon stands claim to love
crypto and Bitcoin and they're big
capitalists and all this [ __ ] and they
have no clue how capitalism works at all
and I can tell just by what they say
about this deal because here's the fact
and the fact remains that if there truly
is a market from Twitter if there truly
is a market for Twitter
either Twitter will fill that market or
someone else will right right that's
capitalism that is what drives the
market and that's what they don't
understand of why Elon really truly
didn't want to buy Twitter at this price
because he had got drenched on this deal
absolutely [ __ ] drenched I I see I
see several different scenarios the most
likely scenario is he destroys Twitter
over time yeah and someone comes in and
fills that market now that's why people
like Facebook and these other social
media Outlets are looking to recruit
their talent because they would like to
I don't know replicate what Twitter is
doing in the market successfully right
and that is where the Gap will be filled
now rather rather it is this
either he destroys Twitter and then has
to sell it for pennies on the dollar
which I believe that's probably what
what will eventually happen is he will
destroy it it will be just a [ __ ]
pile of [ __ ] it won't really be
recoverable so he will have to sell it
for pennies on the dollar
um and it'll probably be done in some
kind of venture capitalist uh you know
scenario because that's really probably
I mean he couldn't even afford this he
had to go to financiers to give him the
money to loan in the money to buy
everything so I think that's probably
what will happen which ultimately
Twitter Will Survive to some degree
possibly
um but but no fear because really the
back of Twitter is the journalist is the
news that's the idea so when you when
you take that marketability out of the
equation and you say well Twitter can't
do it can someone else that's where
other companies are going to swoop in
and if anyone isn't [ __ ] thinking
that there are [ __ ] vultures I mean
straight capitalist vultures right now
playing planning on absolutely [ __ ]
burying Elon Musk and Twitter today as
we speak they're Acro they are in tape
in rooms talking across tables right now
about how they are going to destroy Elon
Musk and Twitter with capitalism right
and they just and they don't understand
it there and there's a couple other
things one I saw someone say they just
joined tribal which is the occupied
Democrats look I'm going to tell you
right now do not join that app okay if
you read the terms of service and what
you're actually agreeing to they can use
your content in advertisements in other
places without your consent they
basically own it anything put on that
website they will own so I don't think
it's going to do very well because
here's the thing that people need to
understand when it comes to social media
apps right you can either have a very
Niche idea and have a very active
Community but you won't have you won't
have a general uh uh child because it's
like you know what you're saying like
like uh like well like a Pinterest or
where where the original idea is very
Niche and
they allowed other kind of monetization
aspects into it so these things you need
to remember that like if you go Niche
like I just mentioned a moment ago like
if you do farmers only right you make
fun of it but there's a a fair amount of
people that are there well okay here
I'll say this there is an active
Community it's not a big Community but
it's a very active Community because
you've got a niche market right now
which is which generally is a profitable
community right yeah and that it can be
right you've got an active actively
highly engaged model you know there's
another thing that's called the 99 one
percent model and when you're dealing
with um the type of audience or
Community ninety percent of people that
join your community will typically just
be lurkers they're just gonna be on it
watching they don't really engage nine
percent of that well then so okay uh
I'll do a little bit of Engagement not a
lot I might tweet or whatever in the
event of of Twitter and there's one
percent that are [ __ ] active they're
tweeting all the time liking retweeting
dming all the stuff they're part of that
Community are you saying are you saying
we're the one percent is that what
you're saying we're part of the one
percent the top one percent we'll say
because at the end it all adds up to
that 100 never been called that before
well you know there's a first time
forever I've been called a lot of things
but never been been accused of being the
one percent so this is this is something
else you've got Jack Dorsey who is
already starting his own social media
company wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait stop right there you're
telling me you're telling me what I was
just saying because there is a person
out there if you could pinpoint a person
Gabe that was like okay if there's one
person that understands what the market
and Twitter is and there's one person
who could probably replicate and fill
that market need who would it be who
would that one person be you know it
might be someone who was formerly the
CEO and one of the people who helped
start uh a social media company like
Twitter oh is who is who's this Jack
Dorsey character again he's this guy you
know he's a guy that uh you know was
well still is he's running square at the
time he still is but also was running
Twitter I mean he's running from
building to building but here's the
thing
you've got a guy who has years of
experience like from the beginning like
2000 2009 2010 right uh or earlier maybe
2008 because he was really there in the
beginning but well I mean because he was
there when um before Twitter was a a
really a big thing right I mean remember
that Twitter before was like all SMS
based you were sending this through a
text message to go online that's a
protocol that they were using to get
these tweets out right well and
originally it was it wasn't it wasn't a
PRI or a public company like because so
many people have this confusion that
that Twitter wasn't always public or
something that yeah no it wasn't always
yeah so the the thing you have to
remember there is that you've got a
company that this guy helped start years
ago and was the CEO of right I mean
there have been other people who see you
and then yeah and I I the other thing
too that you have to keep in mind about
Jack Dorsey is he's the one who made it
he monetized it because it was very
difficult to monetize Twitter right it
was very difficult because they didn't
make it really I mean maybe I'm wrong
but it didn't seem like they made it to
be much monetizing so he worked through
that process right yeah I mean there
were other there were other ways in
which the company makes their money
right what they
were originally doing is basically just
oh if you want to pay to run ads on this
site which is kind of like the
foundation of their monetization there's
other ways that you can make money and
pay for there's also like consumer-based
ones like blue if you want to pay I
think it's like three bucks or ten bucks
or whatever it is to get these certain
features right you know it's like oh I
can edit or redo a tweet within the
first 30 minutes or whatever it is or I
forget the time frame yeah I'm not sure
but when you when you look at these
things you have to remember that this
person has years of experience one of
the companies that is like the [ __ ]
Foundation of society and how we get
information out nowadays right many
people within that team I mean you've
got people from Facebook that's like I
regret inventing the like button right I
regret inventing this aspect of of
Twitter right there are people that are
like oh [ __ ] I did not realize at the
time when I created this that it would
have as big of an impact as it would
today and most likely a negative impact
right if you see the trajectory that
we're on with social media it's not good
right when you're saying when you're
when you're weighing pros and cons is
what you're saying right it can be used
as good however there are external
forces let's say uh Russia other
propaganda other you know conservative
Human Condition Human Condition
people are going to manipulate those
things however they can to better their
situation and social media is just a
tool that can help accelerate that right
so you've got Jack Dorsey creating his
own social media company you've got Elon
Musk who has literally stated there's an
interview
um I don't know if I was having a chat
with you but there's an interview where
he says
what Twitter needs to do is just copy
WeChat and if people don't know what
WeChat is it's basically the
all-encompassing app within China you
can pay through it you can shop through
it you can chat through it you can call
you can do this all day it's everything
everything is connected connected
through WeChat you're basically making
an app that goes in or a way that comes
in through the central repository which
is WeChat and that's the ecosystem that
you live in
what Elon wants to do is create the same
thing now Facebook has already kind of
delved in it's almost right you know
they're like oh well the real the real
tactile world is enough we need to go
meta we need to add legs to these
virtual people which is like that's
where the priorities are nowadays weird
weird so when you when you look at
Twitter and what elon's going to offer
you have to then remember that he
doesn't just like with Tesla just like
with you know SpaceX just like with his
Solar Company these aren't Innovative
yes he's not crazy or Reinventing the
well he is crazy he's not Reinventing
the wheel or rather sorry yeah he's not
Reinventing the wheel he's just creating
what other people have done and copied
it in that shape and form right he's
taking something that China's down with
WeChat and said what we need to do
is buy Twitter copy WeChat make money
those are the three things so if you
begin to see that Trend or those changes
happening on Twitter it's because that's
the idea I'm not saying that they don't
work I'm just saying that when you put
someone in in power who buys a comedy
for 44 billion and a priority is to help
cat turd out with their loss of
followers being Shadow banned probably
not the right person for the job but
also not someone who's going to
challenge the company and Society to
actually better it despite what he
tweets out to advertisers to say this
can't be a free-for-all hellscape right
he's like look free speech is cool I
think uh
it was Trevor Noah yesterday was like
free speech is cool and all but you know
what's even better money right and
that's what it comes down to he says
he's not there to make money but he
ultimately is there to make money he
just spent 13 billion of his own like
Dallas had to sell stock and do this and
do that
he is in it for the money he just spent
13 billion dollars that he has to pay
back to these Banks
and he's 100 in it for the money and
also whatever influence he has right
because we also have to remember there's
a lot of theories out there about right
now Tesla can't sell on actual
dealership Lots you have to go to these
other kind of you have to either order
online or sometimes you there's like
even here in La uh there's a Tesla store
where you can order through right right
but you can't actually go to a
dealership
but what you could do is I don't know
use Twitter as a way to influence the
politics to change those things right or
change the perception because the car
manufacturers are really creeping up on
Tesla right right exactly like the
American car manufacturers were not on
board with the electric cars yeah now
that the American infrastructure will be
changing they're going the American
manufacturers and the foreign
manufacturers that have plants here and
dealerships here like Toyota Kia these
other right um foreign manufacturers
that have plans so when you yeah when
when you're catching up they're catching
up fast they're catching up and when you
look at the comparison of of normal
America not even American you know
companies but you have foreign companies
as well when you look at the
representation of what they offer in
terms of an alternative fuel option
right despite Republicans being like ah
I want gas only uh
you look at what they're offering and
they're like
these things trucks sedans
Vans whatever they might be are offering
an alternative to Tesla a more uh cost
effective alternative to well and a more
address they have a
but I'm but a more attractive one you
keep breaking I mean you've got to keep
breaking you've got uh come
oh sorry what well yes
well because you got like pickup trucks
and different types of vehicles that are
entering into the market which wasn't
there before which Tesla is trying so
hard to get the Tesla truck and these
things but he hasn't been able to do
that because he doesn't have like you
said the infrastructure for the
dealership I think you're good now go
ahead yeah yeah so yeah so I mean I
totally agree it is it is creating that
attractive model and that's really what
it comes down to is like you've got
these companies who finally
finally because Elon Musk didn't invent
the electric car it's been around for a
very long time it was just that these
companies and oil companies and gas
companies wanted to control what was
there because they want to make money I
mean if you look at Q3 profits right it
was Q3 profits that just came out and it
revealed that they're over the you know
in comparison to last year there was a
huge increase right and people need to
understand that it's it's not inflation
that's changing these prices but if the
company the private company itself or
republican traded but the decisions that
these companies are making to say you
know what we should do we should bump up
the price because people really need gas
right now and what we're going to do is
we're going to blame it on this war over
here right or we're going to blame it on
these politics despite the fact that
somebody like Biden and Democrats are
using something that would help fight
the price gouging and Republicans say no
no no we can't actually help the
American people why would you well they
actually want the Republicans want gas
to be high so they can blame it on Joe
Biden and then what they want is after
after this midterm they want it to rise
and keep Rising and keep rising and keep
Rising you keep exactly you keep
freezing um and keep Rising keep Rising
keep re it's probably that deep State
connection you got there it's the CIA
tapping in on that connection probably I
know there I think it's I think I think
where I am right now they're telling me
hey you guys can't go to three hours
right now oh is that what it is because
we are so close to three hours we can't
prove to this audience that we can do
three hours or they'll expect it because
they you are the best audience in the
world and it is Friday and I know we're
just days away from Halloween so
um everyone it's already scary enough
that's right it's scary enough but have
a safe weekend
um again uh we run on your support and I
hate to throw a commercial in here but
um we do run on your support so like
share and get this to your family
members show these clips that we show
every day to those people uh also you
can follow us everywhere on social media
and if you can if you can give a tip you
can go leave a one-time dip or a monthly
dip at Tony Michaels dot live or you can
go to the merch storage store not indeed
Tony michaels.com grab your favorite
merch get Gabe did you see um this uh
here you see the uh the lock them up oh
I did yeah yeah it looks nice that's on
the store active right now so I think
there's a coffee mug some other stuff
with the lock em up on there so if you
want to go grab your banner go grab it
now at store not team Tony D Tony
michaels.com everyone have a great
weekend stay safe have a happy happy uh
um let's see
have a happy Halloween and we will see
you soon we will see you soon as we do
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
right here on YouTube Twitter and twitch
until Monday Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em
foreign
[Music]